SORRY FOR STARTING LATE.
WELCOME AND TO THE AUGUST
NINETEEN ASSEMBLY
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
HEARING. NOTING THE ABSENCE OF
A QUORUM WE WILL BEGIN AS A SUB
COMMITTEE I DO WANT TO START
TODAY BECAUSE THERE SEEMS TO BE
SOME MISINFORMATION ON THE
WORLDWIDE WEB THE IN TWITTER
ABOUT WHAT THIS COMMITTEE IS SO
WE'RE GOING TO DO A QUICK
BRIEFING ABOUT WHAT THIS
COMMITTEE. WE ARE NOT A POLICY
COMMITTEE WE ARE FISCAL
COMMITTEE THAT MEANS
PRESENTATIONS HERE SHOULD ONLY
DEAL WITH THE PHYSICAL ASPECTS
OF THE BILL. THERE ARE
DIFFERENT ALL THE BILLS THAT
COME HERE IN ANY BILL THAT
COSTS MONEY COMES HERE. THEY
ARE DISTRIBUTED IN THREE
DIFFERENT WAYS REALLY IN THIS
COMMITTEE THOSE THAT ARE PUT ON
CONSENT AND ARE NOT TAKEN OFF
WHICH MEANS THEY JUST PASSED
THROUGH AND- USUALLY THERE'S NO.
COMMENTING ON THOSE BILLS.
THERE'S BILLS THAT COST UNDER A
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
IN IT EITHER IS A D<c.cyan> PASSWORD</c>
IT'S NOT. WE USUALLY HAVE A
PRESENTATION WHERE WHERE AT
SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT GET. TO
SPEAKERS GET TWO MINUTES AND
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION TO
THEN BEYOND THAT WE JUST DO ME
TOO. AND THEN THERE'S A WHOLE
GROUP OF BILLS THAT WE PUT ON
SUSPENSE THAT DOESN'T MEAN
THEY'RE BEING KILLED IT'S NOT
IN SUSPENSE IT'S ON SUSPENSE.
AND THAT MEANS. THAT WE WILL
DEAL WITH THOSE AT THE END OF
AUGUST SOMETIMES MOST THE TIME
WHEN MEMBERS ARE. REALLY TRYING
TO MAKE US HAPPY THEY WAVE
PRESENTATION ON SUSPENSE BILLS
IN WHICH CASE THERE'S NO
PRESENTATION. I KNOW EVERYBODY
IN THE AUDIENCE KNOWS THIS BUT
I'M DOING THIS BECAUSE
APPARENTLY IT'S THE SOME PEOPLE
THINK THAT THIS IS. ABNORMAL
BUT WHEN THEY WAY PRESENTATION
WE DON'T HAVE PEOPLE COME TO
THE FRONT AND SIT DOWN AND
PRESENT. WHAT WE ALLOW IS IF
YOU CAME IN THE AUTHOR WAVES
PRESENTATION YOU CAN REGISTER
YOUR SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION TO
THAT BILL. THERE'S A LARGE
GROUP AND THEY WANT TO SPEAK WE
ALLOWED TO PEOPLE TO SPEAK FOR
TWO MINUTES IN SUPPORT IF
THEY'RE HERE. WE DO ALLOW TO
PEOPLE SPEAK IN OPPOSITION FOR
TWO MINUTES EACH BUT EVERYBODY
ELSE HAS TO SIMPLY STATE THEIR
NAME WHO THEY REPRESENT IN
THEIR POSITION. IT DOESN'T
MATTER IF I LOVE YOUR BILL OR
HATE YOUR BILL IT DOESN'T
MATTER WHAT I THINK OF THE
AUTHOR IT DOESN'T MATTER WHAT I
THINK OF YOU PERSONALLY THE
RULES ARE THE SAME FOR
EVERYBODY. I WILL ABIDE BY
THOSE RULES I'M NOT. STRAIGHT
FROM THOSE ROLES AND I'M SORRY
IF IT OFFENDS PEOPLE I AM GOING
TO RUN THIS COMMITTEE THE WAY I
RUN THIS COMMITTEE. FAIRLY FOR
EVERYBODY INVOLVED SO THOSE ARE
THE RULES OF THE ASSEMBLY.
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE WITH
THAT. I HOPE THEY WILL BE.
WIDELY DISTRIBUTED ON THE
INTERNET. WE WILL START AS SOON
AS WE ESTABLISHED QUORUM MADAM
SECRETARY THOSE PRESENT BIGELOW.
BLOOM BONTA BROUGH CALDERON
CARRILLO CHAU DEEP. EGGMAN FONG
GABRIEL GARCIA MAIENSCHEIN
OBERNOLTE PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK
HERE RIVAS. WITH THAT WE WILL
BEGIN WITH SENATOR HILL SENATOR
HILL. IT LOOKS LIKE YOU HAVE A
NUMBER OF BILLS ON CONSENT
YOU'RE NOT PRESENTING ON THOSE
NUMBER BILLS ON SUSPENSE THAT
YOU WAIT PRESENTATION FOR THANK
YOU YOU'LL BE PRESENTING ON TWO
TWO TWO WHICH ENJOYS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION YOU MAY PROCEED
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR
AND COLLEAGUES SB TWO TWENTY
TWO WOULD PROTECT VETERANS AND
MILITARY PERSONNEL FROM HOUSING
DISCRIMINATION AND ENSURE THAT
LANDLORDS CANNOT DENY HOMELESS
VETERANS HOUSING. BASED SOLELY
ON THE FACT THAT THEY RECEIVE A
RENTAL ASSISTANCE ABOUT YOUR
COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH SB
FOURTEEN TWENTY SEVEN OR MINOR
DEPLORABLE THANK YOU I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR RIVAL.
THANK YOU SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT.
SEEN ON SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION
I SEE NINE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
TO KNOW MEASURE THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE WE'RE NEUTRAL THIS
MEASURE. THANK YOU. I KNOW WE
HAVE A MOTION. I HAVE A MOTION
BY MISS KOREA SECOND BY DOCTOR
QUIRK. WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
WITH PROFESSIONAL MEMBERS THANK
YOU. NO I HAVE ONE. THANK IT'S
OUT ON A ROLL CALL WITH MISTER
BURN OFF ROADING THANK YOU.
MISTER MONEY. MISTER MONEY IS
GOING TO WAIVE PRESENTATION ON
HIS SUSPENSE ITEM AND IT LOOKS
LIKE YOU WILL FIRST PRESENT ON
SB SIX FIFTY SEVEN NO NOT
PRESENT SIX EIGHTY EIGHT SB SIX
EIGHTY EIGHT I'M WAVING
PRESENTATION ON THE SUSPENSE
CANDIDATES ONE EIGHTY NINE FIVE
OH FOUR AND SIX FIVE SEVEN SIX
FIVE SEVEN IS NOT A SUSPENSE
LOCATE THEM PULLED FROM CONSENT
SORRY. DO YOU WANT ME TO
PRESENT ON SIX FIVE SEVEN I
WOULD ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE THANK
YOU AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME. SB.
SIX FIFTY SEVEN ENJOYS A DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION IT'S BEEN
MOVED BY DOCTOR QUIRK IT'S BEEN
SECONDED BY MISS CARILLO ARE
THERE SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT.
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE FINANCES
I HAVE A POSITION AT THIS TIME
BUT THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF FOOD AND AGRICULTURE
ESTIMATES ARE NO NO COST
ASSOCIATED WITH THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE. VIRGIN AYE VOTE
THANK YOU THANK YOU. FOR WAIT
WAIT WAIT WAIT. YOU CAN BE LOOK
LIKE FOR ME THAT BILL IS ON
CALL AND WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
NOW TO SB SIX EIGHTY EIGHT
WHICH ENJOYS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION. I THINK DOCTOR
QUIRK WITH TRYING TO MOVE THAT
BILL. YES AND SECOND BY MISS
KOREA THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
EIGHTY EIGHT AND MEMBERS JUST
BRIEFLY SB SIX EIGHTY EIGHT THE
LABOR COMMISSIONER HAS
AUTHORITY TO ASSESS SOME PAID
MINIMUM WAGE AND OVERTIME WAGES
THROUGH A CITATION ISSUED
AGAINST EMPLOYER CONTRACT WAGES
HOWEVER MAY ONLY BE ENFORCED BY
THE LABOR COMMISSIONER THROUGH
A CIVIL ACTION FILED IN
SUPERIOR COURT THIS SENATE BILL
SIX CITY IT GIVES THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER THE AUTHORITY. TO
ASSESS UNPAID CONTRACTUAL WAGES
THROUGH CITATION ISSUED AGAINST
AN EMPLOYER THE BILL HAS MINOR
FISCAL IMPACTS TO THE STATE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU DO WE HAVE SPEAKERS
IN SUPPORT. SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE FINANCES NOT HAVE A
POSITION AT THIS TIME THE
DEPARTMENT OF INDUSTRIAL
RELATIONS ESTIMATES THE FISCAL
IMPACT OF THIS BILLS MINOR AN
OBSERVABLE. RIGHT. REGIONAL
VOTE PLEASE THAT ONE'S ON CALL
THANK YOU SENATOR MONEY. WILL
MOVE NOW TO. MISS COLORADO I
BELIEVE WAS NEXT. SENATE HAVE A
HERO YOU ARE WAVING
PRESENTATION ON YOUR SUSPENSE
CANDIDATES. CORRECT CORRECT AND
YOU'LL BE SAYING ON SB SEVEN
FORTY FOUR SEVEN FORTY FOUR AND
SIX NINE SEVEN SIX NINETY SEVEN
BECAUSE THERE ARE SOME
AMENDMENTS. OKAY THE SO YOU
WANT TO PRESENT ON SIX NINETY
SEVEN FIRST IT IS AB SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE YOU MAY START SO
MADAM CHAIR SIX NINETY SEVEN
MODERNIZES THE PHYSICIAN
ASSISTANTS PRACTICE WE'VE BEEN
WORKING OVER THE PAST YEAR WITH
THAT THE P. A BOARD AND ARE
TAKING SOME AMENDMENTS THAT
BASICALLY REDUCE THE COST TO
NEGLIGIBLE AND SO I WANTED TO
MAKE SURE TO CALL THAT TO YOUR
ATTENTION IT IS LANGUAGE THAT
TO THEM WAS CONFUSING AND SO WE
MADE IT CLEAR SO THAT ONE IS
THEIR THEIR ANALYSIS IS IT'S
MINOR. MINOR AN OBSERVABLE. SO
THIS IS SB SIX NINETY SEVEN IS
OUR SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIRMAN I HAVE
MEMBERS MAKING ALL RIGHT I'M
HAVE THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION JUST APPRECIATE ALL
THE WORK THAT'S BEEN DONE TO
REDUCE THE COSTS. AT HOW IT ALL
OUT OF GAP I JUST THINK THE
SENATOR AND THE AND THE P. A.
B. FOR ALL THE WORK TO REDUCE
THE COST. THE RESPONSE OF THIS
BILL. WE ASK DR OKAY. OF
SUSPENSE. JENNIFER CMOS WITH
THE MEDICAL BOARD OF
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT. OTHER
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION. MANAGER
MEMBERS TO MADDEN WITH
REPRESENT CALIFORNIA CHAPTER
THE MAYOR CALLS IMMERSIVE
FISSIONS WILL IMPOSE LESS
AMENDED POSITION BUT IT'S
LARGELY FOR POLICY REASONS. AND
THAT'S WILL LEAVE IT THERE.
THANK YOU THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE WHEN IS NOT A POSITION
AT THIS TIME AS A BILLS
CURRENTLY IN PRINT THE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS
ESTIMATES OF THE BILL RESULT IN
ANNUAL COST OF THREE HUNDRED
THIRTY FOUR THOUSAND DOLLARS
FOR THE PHYSICIAN ASSISTANTS
BOARD ON THE DEPARTMENT
ESTIMATES THAT ANY FISCAL
IMPACT ASSOCIATE WITH
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY COSTS
ARE LIKELY MINOR ANSWERABLE.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE OR.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
NEIGHBORHOOD ON THE THANK YOU
FOR THAT UPDATE NOT GETS WILL
BE MOVED LATER TO THE SUSPENSE
FILE NOW YOU HAVE SB SEVEN
FORTY FORD ENJOYS A TO PASS
RECOMMENDATION. I YES THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR AT A
MOTION BY DOCTOR QUIRK AT A
SECOND BY MISS KOREA. THAT'S IT
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE
PRECIADO IT THIS THIS HAS TO DO
WITH HOUSING HOMELESS WITH
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES AND IT'S
EXPERT TO EXPEDITE THE PROCESS
OF THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
YOU SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT. TERM
MEMBERS MONICA MILLER BEHALF OF
THE COUNTY ALAMEDA AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING MEMBERS
AGENT RUSSET STEINBERG
INSTITUTE WE ARE THE SPONSRS
OF THIS LEGISLATION COULDN'T BE
MORE PROUD TO. SEE AT
PROPOSITION TO MAKE IT ON TO
THE BALLOT AND- OVERWHELMING
SUPPORT FOR THAT INITIATIVE OF
SUPPORT HOUSING WE THINK THIS
BILL ADDS TO THAT AND- FULFILL
THAT PROMISE. THANK YOU THANK
YOU ADDITIONAL SUPPORTERS.
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION. FINANCE
WE DO NOT HAVE A POSITION AT
THIS TIME THE BUSINESS CONSUMER
SERVICES AND HOW TO HOUSING
AGENCY THE DEPARTMENT OF
HOUSING COMMITTEE DEVELOPMENT
AND THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL
ESTIMATE THEY WILL NOT HAVE
ADDITIONAL COSTS AS A RESULT OF
THIS BILL ADDITIONALLY FINANCE
NOTES THAT THIS BILL DOES NOT
CREATE A STATE REIMBURSABLE
MANDY BECAUSE THE AFFECTED
LOCAL AGENCIES HAVE THE
AUTHORITY TO LEVY FEES.
SUFFICIENT TO PAY FOR THE
HIGHER LEVEL SERVICE. THANK
YOU. WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE THAT GETS OUT ON A ROLL
CALL WITH MR BIGELOW VOTING NO
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU SENATOR. NEXT MEETING
WITH MISTER DODD. SENATOR DODD
I HAVE YOU IT LOOKS LIKE
PRESIDING IN SB TWENTY IT
ENJOYS A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION.
WE HAVE A MOTION BY MISTER
BROLL IN A SECOND BY A DOCTOR
QUIRK. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS I SB TWENTY WOULD ALLOW
NAPA COUNTY TO NEGOTIATE WITH
THE D. G. S. TO BY EIGHT
HUNDRED FIFTY ACRE SKYLINE
WILDERNESS PARK INSURING THIS
PRIME PARK LAND WITH POPULAR
HIKING TRAILS AND VIEWS OF THE
BAY AREA. REMAINS A PUBLIC PARK
IN PERPETUITY SB TWENTY WOULD
ALLOW THE STATE TO SELL OR
EXCHANGE OF FAIR MARKET VALUE
SCOTT IN PART TO THE COUNTY OR
NAPA COUNTY REGIONAL PARK IN
OPEN SPACE DISTRICT TO ENSURE
ITS PRESERVATION. AS REPORTED
BY THE DEAL AFTER THE BILL WILL
HAVE NO. FISCAL IMPACT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIGHT. THANK
YOU SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT IN TURN
MEMBERS CAROLING UNDER THE NAPA
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
THEY LEASE THE PROPERTY NOW FOR
ONE HUNDRED DOLLARS A YEAR IT
EXPIRES IN TWENTY THIRTY IF
THEY WERE TO SELL IT WOULD
ACTUALLY BE BENEFICIAL TO THE
STATE FINANCIALLY MASK FOR
EITHER TODAY THANK YOU. THANK
YOU ADDITIONAL SUPPORTERS.
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION. SEE
NINE DEPARTMENT FINANCE FINANCE
NOW HAS THE OPPOSE POSITION ON
THIS BILL BECAUSE IT IS
PREMATURE THE DEPARTMENT
GENERAL SERVICES IS STILL
REVIEWING THE SKYLINE PARK IF
IT IS SUITABLE OPTION FOR A
LONG TERM LEASE FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING DEVELOPMENT PURSUANT TO
EXECUTIVE ORDER AND DASH OH SIX
DASH NINETEEN. THE LAND IS PART
OF THE NOT HOSPITAL PROPERTY
AND THE DEPARTMENT OF STATE
HOSPITALS IS IN THE PROCESS OF
ASSESSING THE PROGRAMMATIC
NEEDS ACROSS ALL FIVE OF THEIR
FACILITIES. THE DEPARTMENT OF
GENERAL SERVICES NO THAT'S ON
THE PROPERTY COULD RESULT IN
HIGHER LONG TERM COSTS. IF THE
STATE NEEDS TO ACQUIRE
ADDITIONAL PROPERTY TO
ACCOMMODATE FUTURE GROWTH.
ADDITIONALLY IF I PHËN. N<c.cyan></c>
THAT SELLING THE PROPERTY RULES
ALL AND ONE TIME REVENUE FROM
THE SALE. OF THE VALUE OF THE
PROPERTY IS UNKNOWN AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU. I SEE NO
QUESTIONS WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE A YES AS FAR AS THAT COME
A BY THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
THE COUNTY ALREADY KNOWS THIS
THE GOVERNOR'S EXECUTIVE ORDER
TOOK TWENTY ACRES OF THIS
PROPERTY THE COUNTY UNDERSTANDS.
THAT AND IS WOULD YOU KNOW
REALLY SUPPORTER OF. OF MORE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN THEIR
COMMUNITY AT THAT SHOULDN'T
POSE ANY PROBLEM WHATSOEVER. TO
THIS GOING FOR THEIR SEVEN
HUNDRED FIFTY EIGHT ACRES OF
HILLS TWENTY ACRES OF FLAT
LAND. YEAH THAT IS PROPOSED BY
DEPARTMENT AT. IDG ASKED TO BE
SET ASIDE FOR HOUSING. PERFECT
ASK RIVAL THANK YOU THAT COULD
HAPPEN IN A ROLL CALL THANK YOU
SENATOR DODD. MR LOW. I WILL
EXPLAIN AGAIN THAT THIS IS THE
THIRD ACA WE ARE HEARING AND
NOT PUTTING ON SUSPENSE DESPITE
THE COST AND THAT IS JUST A
PARITY ISSUE WITH THE SENATE
WHEN WE REACH FOR ACA'S WE WILL
PUT THE REST ON SUSPENSE BUT
WELCOME MR LOTUS ENJOYS A DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION ACA EIGHT
YOU MAY PROCEED THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND CHAIR AND MEMBERS THIS
IS A C. EIGHT THE CONSTANT
AMENDED TO LOWER THE VOTING AGE
FROM EIGHTEEN TO SEVENTEEN AND
RESPECT ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT GOOD
MORNING CHECK INTO ROMERO WITH
THE CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS PROUD TO BE
SPONSORS OF THE ACA EIGHT OF
COURSE THIS BILL WOULD ASK
VOTERS TO LOWER THE VOTING AGE
SEVENTEEN WHICH IS WHAT THE
COSTS ASSOCIATED AND THERE WERE
REFERRED TO IN THE IN THE
ANALYSIS WE APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY MOVE THIS IMPORTANT
BILL FOR IT THANKS. THANK YOU.
ADDITIONAL SUPPORTERS.
OPPONENTS. ANYBODY IN
OPPOSITION DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. FINANCES NEUTRAL ON
THIS MEASURE TO EXPAND VOTING
RIGHTS BUT NOTES CONCERNS AT
THE BILL WILL INCREASE COSTS TO
THE SECRETARY OF STATE TO PRINT
A MILITIA VOTING MATERIALS TO
THE MEASURE BE PASSED THE
SECRETARY SECRETARY OF STATE
ESTIMATES ADDITIONAL ONE TIME
COST OF ONE HUNDRED SEVENTY
FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS GENERAL
FUND IN FISCAL YEAR TWENTY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TO UPDATE
INFORMATION PRINTED DOCUMENTS
ON WEBSITES AND OTHER VARIOUS
COST RANGING IN. IN THE RANGE
OF FIFTEEN THOUSAND DOLLARS TO
THIRTY FOUR THOUSAND DOLLARS
AND A REQUEST FOR ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES IS SUBJECT REVIEW
THROUGH THE- BUDGET PROCESS.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS. SEEN NONE YOU DON'T
ENVIRONMENT. SO THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT ALLEGE OFF I WANTED HIM
TO MAKE IT SIXTEEN MY CONCERNS
WITH THIS BILL AND I WILL STATE
THEM IS ALTHOUGH THE COST FOR
PRINTING BALLOTS IS WHAT IT IS
YOU KNOW AND WE HAVE NO PROBLEM
WITH THAT IS BECAUSE
CONGRESSIONAL ELECTIONS IN
FEDERAL ELECTIONS WOULD NOT BE
ASSESSED WHAT SEVENTEEN YEAR
OLDS WE WOULD HAVE AT LARGE
COSTS FOR REGISTER VOTERS IN
DIFFERENT AND COUNTIES TO PRINT
TWO SETS OF BALLOTS IN
PRESIDENTIAL IN. CONGRESSIONAL
ELECTIONS SO THAT IS SOMETHING
THAT WE NEED TO ADDRESS I THINK
IN FUTURE YEARS IF THEY SHOULD
GO FORWARD AND PASS AND I HOPE
IT DOES I ALSO HOPE YOU
RECONSIDER CHANGING TO SIXTEEN
BECAUSE THAT IS WHAT A MAJORITY
OF THE MOVEMENT ONCE AND WE
WOULDN'T HATE TO DO THIS TIME
AND TIME AGAIN SO WITH THAT I
DO AS- WE HAVE A MOTION AND
SECOND. A MOTION. MOVE THE BILL
I MISS KOREA A SECOND BY. MR
GABRIEL. NOW IS THAT YES I'M
SORRY IT WASN'T SURE WHO SAID
THAT ALL RIGHT. WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE. I JUST WANT TO
RECOGNIZE THE BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT FOR THIS MEASURE AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK VERY VOTE AND
I GETS OUT ON A B. ROLL CALL
WITH MR DIEPPE VOTING I AM MR
MAIENSCHEIN NOT VOTING. THANK
YOU. AT THIS POINT I'D LIKE TO
DISPENSE OF SB SIX FIFTY SEVEN
BY MISTER MONEY IN THAT GETS
OUT ON A B. ROLL CALL WITH MR
PEROT NOT VOTING MISTER YET
VOTING. I AM MR OBERNOLTE
VOTING HIGH. ALL RIGHT IT LOOKS
LIKE WE ARE MISTER BELL. FROM
FROM. MISTER BELL AND. LET'S
START WITH SB FOUR EIGHTY FIVE
IT ENJOYS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION. THANK YOU. SB
WE HAVE A LARGE FIVE OKAY WE
HAVE A MOTION BY MISS KOREA WE
HAVE A SECOND BY DOCTOR QUIRK.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR THIS BILL
IS. PROHIBITS THE SUSPENSIONS
OF A DRIVER'S LICENSE FOR NON
VEHICLE RELATED CRIME. THE
METHOD OF PUNISHMENT HAS NOT
PROVEN TO INCREASE PUBLIC
SAFETY. AND IT ADDS WORKLOAD TO
THE DEPARTMENT OF MOTOR
VEHICLES. WHICH WE DON'T NEED
AND FINANCIAL BURDEN ON LOW
INCOME FAMILIES AND PEOPLE
COLOR THE BILL RESULT IN TV AND
COURT COST SAVINGS BY
ELIMINATING INEFFICIENT
PROCESSES AND ALLOW PEOPLE TO
CARE FOR THE CHILDREN WORK
MAINTAIN EMPLOYMENT. AND PAVE
RESTITUTION. I REGION I VOTE ON
THIS BILL. I HAVE WITNESSES. WE
HAVE WITNESSES IN SUPPORT I'M
SORRY GO. LAURIE TO ON BEHALF
OF THE COVERS CALIFORNIA BAR
ASSOCIATIONS WITH THE SPONSOR
OF THE BILL IN ADDITION THE
FISCAL OFFENSE SENATOR BILL
PRETTY MENSCH MENTIONED WE
BELIEVE THE BILL MAY ACTUALLY
SAVE MONEY IT DOES NOT
ELIMINATE EITHER THE FINES FOR
VIOLATION OF THE STATUES NOR
THE VINYL THERE'S
RESPONSIBILITY TO PAY COURT
ORDERED DEBT. BUT THE
DEFENDANT'S ABILITY TO PAY
FINES MAY WELL INCREASE BECAUSE
OF THEIR NEW ABILITY TO KEEP
AND HOLD A JOB WITH A VALID
LICENSE BECAUSE THEY DON'T HAVE
TO BREAK THE LAW TO GET TO
WORK. WE THINK THAT'LL RESULT
IN ADDITIONAL REVENUE TO THE
STATE AND WE URGE YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ADDITIONAL SUPPORTERS.
CHECK EVERY WERE THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATIONS SO FOR CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
OTHER SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
SEE NINE DEPARTMENT FINANCE
FINANCES NEUTRAL ON THIS
MEASURE BUT KNOWS CONCERNS AT
THE BILL REMOVES THE COURT'S
DISCRETION TO DETERMINE IF THE
SPENDING DRIVING PRIVILEGES AND
IS APPROPRIATE PUNISHMENT FOR
THE PARTICULAR CASE BEING
ADJUDICATED. THANK YOU WITH
THAT WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
ALL RIGHT AND WE'RE GONNA PUT
THAT ON CALL WE NEED ONE MORE
DEMOCRATS TO COME TO THE
COMMITTEE. MISTER BELL ARE YOU
GOING TO PRESENT ON A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE AS WELL I HAVE ONE
SUSPENSE KIND OF LIKE TO
PRESENT THIS SB TEN ALRIGHT.
YOU MAY PROCEED SB TEN IS. OKAY.
THANK YOU SB TEN IS RIDER
CERTIFICATION BILL OF THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR TO ALLOWING US TO
PRESENT THIS BILL IT
ESTABLISHES A STATEWIDE
pSPECIALIST NOW APPEAR PROVIDER
IS A PERSON WHO HAS LIVED
EXPERIENCE WITH THE MENTAL
HEALTH ILLNESS AND SUBSTANCE
USE DISORDER SPECIAL SPECIALLY
TRAINED TO SUPPORT OTHERS AND I
THINK IS WHAT WHAT WHAT HAS
BEEN LEFT OUT OF OUR
CONVERSATION HERE IS THE VALUE
OF THESE PROGRAMS. THIS IS LOW
HANGING FRUIT FOR CALIFORNIA TO
INCREASE OUR MENTAL HEALTH
WORKFORCE AND IMPROVE SERVICE
NOW DOUBT A OF SHOWS A CLEAR
RETURN ON INVESTMENT PEERS ARE
PART OF A MENTAL HEALTH SYSTEM.
AND IN FACT THAT'S WHY. OF IT
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IN TWO
THOUSAND SEVEN URGE US TO DO
THIS AND FORTY EIGHT OUT OF THE
FIFTY STATES HAVE ALREADY DONE
THIS. LET ME REPEAT THAT FORTY
EIGHT OF THE FIFTY STATES HAVE
ALREADY DONE THIS THERE'S ONLY
TWO STATES THAT HAVEN'T. AND
ONE OF THEM IS CALIFORNIA. SO
WE'RE BEHIND WE APPEARS DOING
AMAZING WORK BUT WITHOUT
CERTIFICATION OR STANDARDS.
MEDICAID REIMBURSES FIFTY
PERCENT. OF THE COST OF YOUR
SERVICES. IN STATES WITH THE
CERTIFICATION STANDARDS. AND OF
COURSE PEERS CAN SAVE MONEY AND.
I'M SURE ALL TURNED OVER MY
WITNESSES. AND WE HAVE THE
CHAIR OF THE. MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES ACT COMMISSION WITH US
TODAY KATARA AND TEMPLIN AND
SHE WILL MAKE A PRESENTATION
THE CHAIR OF OUR MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES THAT COMMISSION. THANK
YOU SENATOR VALUE HAD TWO
MINUTES GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIR AND ON A PER LEGISLATORS
MENISCUS TEAR TEMPLE AND I'M
THE CONSUMER POWER MANAGER FOR
ALAMEDA COUNTY BEHAVIOR HEALTH
AND THE CHAIR OF MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES OVERSIGHT KIND ABILITY
COMMISSION. AND A PERSON WHO'S
UTILIZED BOTH PUBLIC AND
PRIVATE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
I STARTED RECEIVING PUBLIC
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES AS A
CHILD AFTER MY FAMILY ESCAPED
AFGHANISTAN WHEN I WAS THREE I
AM DEEPLY HONORED TO TESTIFY
TODAY IN SUPPORT OF SB TEN AND
THE COST BENEFITS OF IT.
THROUGHOUT THE STATE PEERS
PROVIDERS AND FAMILY MEMBERS
ALL HAVE BEEN WORKING ON PAYER
CERTIFICATION SINCE TWO
THOUSAND AND FOUR WHEN THE
VOTERS OF CALIFORNIA PASSED
PROPOSITION SIXTY THREE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES ACT. SB TEN
YOUR SUPPORT CERTIFICATION IS
ALIGNED WITH THE VISION OF PROP
SIXTY THREE PER SUPPORTERS. ARE
DISTINCT TYPE OF PER. STONE
WOULD LIVE. THE SERVICE IS AN
EVIDENCE BASED PRACTICE SB TEN
HONORS ALL OF THAT AND FOLLOWS
THE FRAMEWORK OF PHOTO OF OUR
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT'S GUIDANCE
THE STATE'S. IRAN APPEAR
ORGANIZATION WE PARTNERED WITH
OUR LOCAL PSYCH HOSPITAL ON A
PROJECT THAT WAS FUNDED BY
IMAGES SAY INNOVATION DOLLARS.
THIS PROGRAM PAIRED. A TRAIN
PAIR WAS SOMEONE CURRENTLY THE
PSYCH HOSPITAL. WHO ALSO HAD A
LEAST TWO HOSPITALIZATIONS THAT
YEAR. THE RESULTS WERE
OUTSTANDING. AND WHAT I HOPE
STAYS WITH YOU. THERE WAS A 72%
REDUCTION AND RE
HOSPITALIZATION A HUNDRED AND
TWENTY FIVE HOSPITAL ADMISSIONS
AVOIDED ONE PROGRAM. BUDGET OF
TWO HUNDRED AND THIRTY EIGHT
THOUSAND DOLLARS SAVE THE
SYSTEM ONE POINT SIX TWO
MILLION DOLLARS PLEASE SUPPORT
SUPPORT SB TENSE THE MORE
CALIFORNIA'S CAN HAVE ACCESS TO
THIS EVIDENCE BASED LIFESAVING
AND COST EFFECTIVE. PRACTICE
THANK YOU THANK YOU ADDITIONAL
SUPPORTERS. HI JASON ROBINSON I
AM. JASON ROBINSON AND THE
BOARD MEMBER OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF MENTAL HEALTH
CURE RUN ORGANIZATIONS AND ALSO
SAMPSON SUBSTANCE ABUSE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES ADMINISTRATION
RECOVERY MONTH PLANNING PARTNER
ON A PERSON WITH LIVED
EXPERIENCE AND RECOVERY FROM
MENTAL HEALTH AND SUBSTANCE USE
ISSUES AND I AM THE PROGRAM
DIRECTOR OF A PURE RUN
ORGANIZATION LOS ANGELES COUNTY
THEY RECEIVED FUNDING THROUGH
THE DEPARTMENT OF MENTAL
HEALTH. AND IN RESPONSE TO THE
FISCAL ANALYSIS DONE BY THE
COMMITTEE I HOPE TO POINT OUT
THAT YOUR SERVICES ARE EXISTING
IN CALIFORNIA YOU RUN
ORGANIZATIONS ARE WELL WELL
POSITIONED TO ESCALATE. AND
SCALE YOUR SERVICES AS THEY
STAND. SERVICES MITIGATE THE
COST OF OVERALL MENTAL HEALTH.
PROVISION CALIFORNIA HAS A 38%
RE HOSPITALIZATION RATE IN
PSYCHIATRIC SERVICES TWICE THE
NATIONAL AVERAGE. PURE RUN
SERVICES ARE THE MITIGATING
FACTORS THAT DETERMINE WHETHER
PEOPLE GET RE HOSPITALIZED OR
NOT RE HOSPITALIZED AS COULD
TERRACE PROGRAM POINTS OUT IN
LOS ANGELES COUNTY ROUND ONE OF
THE AN HSA INNOVATIONS PROGRAMS
FOUND THAT THE COST OF SOMEBODY
GOING TO APPEAR RUN RESPITE WAS
ON AVERAGE FOUR HUNDRED ELEVEN
DOLLARS PER PERSON PER DAY.
COMPARED TO THE COST OF
SOMEBODY GOING TO A PSYCHIATRIC
HOSPITALIZATIONS WHO'S OVER A
THOUSAND DOLLARS. ONLY
REFERRING SOMEBODY TO A SELF
HELP SUPPORT GROUP IN THE
COMMUNITY THROUGH THE USE OF
PEERS CUTS RE HOSPITALIZATION
BY 50% AND IN RESPONSE TO THE
FISCAL ANALYSIS BY THE
COMMITTEE AGAIN. THE SCALE OF
COSTS FOR PURE CERTIFICATION
THE TRAINING. IS ALREADY
HAPPENING THROUGH OUR SPREAD
THROUGH STATEWIDE AND PEER RUN
ORGANIZATIONS ARE AT THE
FOREFRONT OF THAT AND CAN TAKE
ON THE BURDEN OF THAT WORK
THANK YOU AND I HEARD YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU ADDITIONAL
SUPPORTERS. GOOD MORNING ADRIN
CHILTON STEINBERG INSTITUTE
PROUD SPONSOR OF THIS
LEGISLATION THANK YOU THANK YOU
WHAT'S GONNA SAY OUR NAME THE
ORGANIZATION OR POSITION. GOOD
MORNING HEIDI STRONG FOR THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION AND
SOCIALREHABILITATION AGENCIES
IN SUPPORT. AS WELL AS I'M HERE
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
COALITION. FOR MENTAL HEALTH
AND SUPPORT AS WELL THANK YOU.
CHECK A FREIGHTER NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORK
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT.
GILLIAN CATS LIMóN ABOUT HALF
OF SENATOR FAMILY OF AGENCIES
AMPLE SUPPORT. DONNA SIDE TRIPS
IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS ONE OF THE CO
SPONSORS OF THE BILL IN SUPPORT.
DANNY OFFER WITH THE NATIONAL
ALLIANCE ON MENTAL ILLNESS ALSO
KNOWS NOT ME CALIFORNIANS
STRONG SUPPORT. KELLY BROOKS ON
BEHALF OF THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA HEALTH CARE
DISTRICTS THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF PUBLIC HOSPITALS
AND HEALTH SYSTEMS AND THE
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS OF
SANTA CLARA AND THEN TRY
COUNTIES IN SUPPORT. THE BILL
GOT ON BEHALF OF THE COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
CAROLINE ON THE FOR THE HUBBLE
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN
SUPPORT. SYLVIA SOLELY SHAUN
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF SANTA
MONICA AND SUPPORT. PERCENT
DOES HERE WE AT THE CALIFORNIA
ACADEMY OF CHILD AND ADOLESCENT
PSYCHIATRY IN SUPPORT. ERIC
HARRIS WITH DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT. IS THAT
SHORT ON BEHALF OF PEACH THE
PRIVATE ESSENTIAL ACCESS
COMMUNITY HOSPITALS AND SUPPORT.
TO MATTERS IN CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER OF THE AMERICAN COLLEGE
OF EMERGENCY PHYSICIANS IN
SUPPORT. RIGHT IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION. SEE NINE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE FINANCE DOES NOT
HAVE A POSITION AT THIS TIME OF
THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES ESTIMATES REQUIRES
FIFTEEN POSITIONS AND TWO POINT
EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS AND
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY AND
TWENTY FOUR POSITIONS AND SIX
POINT FOUR MILLION DOLLARS AND
TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND
ANNUALLY THEREAFTER TO
IMPLEMENT PROVISIONS OF THIS
BILL AND BECAUSE RESOURCES
WOULD BE SUBJECT TO REVIEW AND
APPROVAL TO THE ANNUAL BUDGET
PROCESS. THE OFFICE OF
STATEWIDE HEALTH PLANNING AND
DEVELOPMENT NOTES COST TO
CONSULT WITH DH CS FOR
STAKEHOLDER MEETINGS IMAGING
THE PURE SUPPORT SPECIAL
CERTIFICATION PROGRAM WILL BE
MINOR AN OBSERVABLE THIS BILL
ALSO RESULTS AND PROP THIRTY
COST TO THE COUNTY MENTAL
HEALTH PLANS FOR PROVISIONS OF
SEVERE. MENTAL HEALTH CARE AND
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER
TREATMENT THE COST COULD RANGE
FROM THE THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS
TO THE MILLIONS OF DOLLARS AND
WOULD BE BORNE BY THE GENERAL
FUND. THANK YOU MISTER BELL
THIS IS GOING TO SUSPEND WHICH
I CLOSE. THANK YOU URGENT EVOKE
WHEN SUSPENSE ITEM IS
CONSIDERED THANK YOU THANK YOU.
WELL MISTER BRADFORD COMES UP
I'M GONNA DISPENSED OF ONE
OTHER BILL SB SIX EIGHTY EIGHT
BY MISTER BONNIE THAT GETS OUT
ON A. B. ROLL CALL WITH MR GET
VOTING HIGH. MR REID FOR YOU'LL
BE PRESENTING ON SB FIVE THIRTY
FOUR ENJOYS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION. WE MOTION BY
MISCREANTS SECOND BY DOCTOR
QUIRK. THINK ABOUT YOUR MEMBERS
THIS IS VERY SIMPLE BILLS
INSURANCE VERSATILE DIVERSITY
HE JUST RISK DOLLARS JUST
INSURANCE PART VIRTUE SURVEY IT
CODIFIES THE GOVERNING BOARDUP
DIVERSITY SURVEY AND IT. ALSO
CODIFIED INSURANCE DIVERSITY
TASK FORCE WHICH WILL BE MADE
UP OF FIFTEEN MEMBERS APPOINTED
BY OUR INSURANCE COMMISSIONER
RESPECT OUT FOR A VOTE. THANK
YOU ARE THERE SPEAKERS IN
SUPPORT. SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE FINANCES
NEUTRAL ON THIS MEASURE BUT
KNOWS CONCERNS THAT WILL RESULT
IN MINOR ONGOING COST TO THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE CDI AND ANTICIPATES
IS BELOW COST TWENTY ONE
THOUSAND DOLLARS AND TWENTY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND TWELVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO AN ON
GOING TO VICE CITY IS AYE AYES
CONFLICT OF INTEREST CODE
REGULATIONS TO INCLUDE MEMBERS
OF THE TASK FORCE. TO COVER THE
COSTS OF MEMBERS TO ATTEND
QUARTERLY MEETINGS. YOU SEE NO
QUESTIONS WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. RESPECT US THROUGH A
VOTE THAT GETS OUT ON A B. ROLL
CALL WITH MR BIGELOW AND MR
FONG NOT VOTING THANK YOU THANK
YOU MA'AM
. SORRY TRYING TO MAKE
SURE I GET THIS RIGHT MISTER
BOARD YES. THIS IS THE FIRST
TIME I'VE HAD A STATE YOUR NAME
ALLOWED SO I WANTED TO MAKE
SURE I DIDN'T. SB FOUR OH TO
ENJOY THE DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION. THE MEASURE BY
DOCTOR QUIRK IN A SECOND BY
MISTER FONG. YOU MAY PROCEED I.
THANK YOU I THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS THE UP TO
PRESENT THIS BILL TODAY IT AS
BEFORE TO IS A FIVE YEAR
EXTENSION IN YOUR COUNTIES
ADVENTURE TRAIL PILOT PROGRAM
AS NOTED IN THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS ANY COST TO THE STATE
WOULD BE MINOR AN OBSERVABLE I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE ON AS BEFORE TO. INGEST IT
WITH YOUR PERMISSION THE
ABILITY TO INTRODUCE. IN YOUR
COUNTY SUPERVISOR MATT KINGSLEY
SO WE CAN BRIEFLY INTRODUCE
HIMSELF WITH YOUR PERMISSION
THANK YOU YES THE TWO MINUTES
YOU MAY I I'M UNDER TWO MY
NAME'S MATT KINGSLEY ON THE
FIFTH DISTRICT SUPERVISOR FROM
INYO COUNTY I'M HERE TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS AND I JUST
SUPPORT POSITION. THANK YOU
ADDITIONAL SUPPORTERS. MARIAN
WARMER COUNTIES IN SUPPORT. ARE
THERE ANY SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION. SCENE NINE
DEPARTMENT FINANCE FINANCES
NEUTRAL JOINT CLOSE.
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST DRIVER
THANK IT'S OUT ON A ROLL CALL
WITH MR BLOOM VOTING NO THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. MR ALLEN LOOKS
LIKE YOU'RE UP NEXT. IT LOOKS
LIKE YOU HAVE TO BILLS YOU'LL
BE PRESENTING NOT AND NO MORE
THAN TWO RIGHT BUT WE HAVE
THREE MANAGER THREE BELLS I
JUST WANT TO. COMPLIMENT THE
COMMITTEE ON THE GREAT FLAGS.
THE VERY DRAMATICALLY PLACED. I
DIDN'T NOTICE THAT YEAH WELL
IT'S A SOMEBODY'S FREEING ME
QUITE WELL AS A GOOD VISUAL TO
GIVE VISUAL GET STATE HANDS
AROUND HERE MISTER ALLEN WILL
START WITH SB FORTY SEVEN IT
ENJOYS A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION
SO THIS BILL REQUIRES SIGNATURE
GATHERERS TO PROVIDE CALIFORNIA
VOTERS WITH KNOWLEDGE ABOUT
WHO'S PAYING TO QUALIFY IN
INITIATIVE REFERENDUM A RECALL
AT THE MOMENT AT THE TIME THAT
THEY'RE CONTEMPLATING WHETHER
TO SIGN THE PETITION WHEN
THEY'RE STANDING OUTSIDE THE-
SUPERMARKET SO. AYE AYES THIS
COMMITTEES ANALYSIS STATE STATE
COSTS ARE NEGLIGIBLE I HAVE
HERE I'VE TRENT LANGE'S PRESENT
THE INVECTIVE DIRECTOR THE
COMPANY. CLEAN MONEY CAMPAIGN
TO TESTIFY. IN OUR STEADFAST
FOREVER. HI THE- MORNING
COMMITTEE TRAVELING CALIFORNIA
MONEY CAMPAIGN PROUD TO SPONSOR
SB FORTY SEVEN. IT'S A SIMPLE
STRAIGHTFORWARD EXTENSION OF
THE CALIFORNIA DISCLOSE ACT OF
THIS LEGISLATURE PASSED MAKE
SURE THAT INITIATIVE SIGNATURE
GATHERERS HAVE TO WITH A COVER.
IT'S BEEN DESIGNED TO HAVE AS
LOW COST AS POSSIBLE FOR
SIGNATURE GATHERERS THEY CAN.
JUST PUT THE TOP THREE FUNDERS
ON OFFICIAL TOP FUNDER SHEET
THAT THAT ANY SIGNATURE GATHER
CAN SIMPLY PRINT OUT. UPDATED
ONCE A MONTH SO THE SUGGEST WE
HAVE TO UPDATE AND JUST PRINT
ON A PIECE OF PAPER ONCE A
MONTH. SO WE THINK THIS IS A
VERY REASONABLE APPROACH TO
MAKE SURE VOTERS UNDERSTAND WHO
IS THAT BEHIND IN ISSUES
THEY'RE BEING ASKED. TO SIGN
AND- RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
DRIVER THANK YOU. WE HAVE A
MUCH BY MR GABRIEL AND AS
SECOND BY MISTER OBERNOLTE.
ADDITIONAL SPEAKERS AS PART.
NICHOLAS HAD ON WITH COMMON
CAUSE IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK
YOU ARE THERE ANY SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION. SEE NINE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE FINANCES NEUTRAL IN
THIS BILL BUT KNOWS CONCERNS
THAT IT IS UNCLEAR HOW OFTEN
THE DISCLOSURE STATEMENT MUST
BE UPDATED TO ENSURE THE MOST
RECENT AND UP TO DATE OFFICIAL
TOP UNDER INFORMATION IS
PROVIDED. IF THIS INFORMATION
IS NEED TO BE UPDATED
FREQUENTLY THIS BILL MAY RESULT
IN PETITIONS NOT RECEIVING
ENOUGH SIGNATURES. THANK YOU.
MANAGER CAN I JUST RESPECTFULLY
ASK MY WHICH IS THE VERY
QUICKLY CLARIFY I THINK IT'S
VERY CLEAR AYE AYE AYE AYE MY
SENSE A DIFFERENT FEINSTEIN. NO
SE NOW THERE'S NO NEED AND SO
WE HEARD FROM YOUR WITNESS A
YOU CAN. YOU CAN CLOSE IF YOU'D
LIKE I WAS GONNA ASK TO BE A-
CO AUTHOR ON THIS BILL I. WOULD
YOU KNOW TAKE YES I APPRECIATE
THAT VERY MUCH. YEAH SO THANK
YOU MADAM MADAM CHAIR. AYE AYE
AYE MY ONLY POINT IS THAT ON
THE BILL'S VERY CLEAR THAT THEY
HAVE TO GET THE ONCE A MONTH.
AND HAPPY TO WORK WITH HER TO
FIND TO GET THAT CLARIFIED BUT
I DO APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT A
GREAT DEAL AND I RESPECT FASTER
ABOUT. THANK YOU THAT GETS OUT
ON A B. ROLL CALL WITH MISTER
OR FONG NOT VERY MISTER
OBERNOLTE VOTING HI. THANK YOU
MISTER ALLEN YOUR NEXT BILL IS
SB TO. TWELVE IN ENJOYS EIGHT
DO PASS RECOMMENDATION. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR THIS BILL
AUTHORIZES GENERAL LOST CITIES
COUNTIES AND SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
TO UTILIZE MAJORITY WINNER
VOTING METHODS FOR LOCAL
ELECTIONS EITHER TOP TWO
PRIMARY WERE RANKED CHOICE
VOTING IF THEY WANT TO THIS IS
A PERMISSIVE BILL. IN
JURISDICTIONS CAN CHOOSE TO OPT
IN GENES ARE ELECTION IF IT IF
THEY WANT TO. SECTOR STATE
ESTIMATES ONE TIME MINOR COSTS
APPROXIMATELY FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS TO DEVELOP REGULATIONS.
VERY SMALL AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR A VOTE TO GIVE. OUR
CITIES SO MORE TOOLS MORE
OPTIONS WITH REGARDS TO HOW
THEY- CONDUCT THEIR ELECTIONS.
IN A FAIR WAY. WE HAVE A MOTION
BY DR MARCUS I CAN BY MR
GABRIEL SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT.
BECAUSE I DON'T ON BEHALF OF
SERVICE SPONSORS BILL IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU ARE THERE
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE THE
SECRETARIES THE ESTIMATES ONE
TIME COSTS OF APPROXIMATELY
FORTY NINE THOUSAND GENERAL
FUND TO DRAFT REGULATIONS
RELATED TO IMPLEMENTING RANGE
TOWARDS VOTING HOWEVER FINANCE
BELIEVES THESE CALLS ARE MINOR
AND CAN LIKELY BE ABSORBED
WITHIN THE SECRETARY OF STATE'S
EXISTING BUDGET. THANK YOU THE
QUICKEST QUESTION SO SAN
FRANCISCO OAKLAND SAN LEANDRO
ALL WENT TO THIS TYPE OF SYSTEM
HOW DO WITH IT WITHOUT I THINK
A SPECIAL BILL UP WHAT WOULD
YOUR BILL REALLY CHANGE SO
THANK YOU MISTER GORE THOSE ARE
THOSE ARE CHARTER CITIES SO
THOSE CITIES HAVE THE RIGHT TO
DO IT UNDER THE UNDER LAW
ALREADY THIS WOULD ALLOW
GENERAL I CITIES IF THEY WANT
TO. THANK YOU WHAT THEY DID.
THANK YOU. WHICH I CLOSE
RESPECT PRICE RATHER THAT GETS
OUT ON A B. ROLL CALL THANK YOU
MISTER ALLEN YOUR LAST BILL IS
SB SIX SEVENTY SEVEN IT ENJOYS
A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION. WE
HAVE. A MOTION BY DOCTOR QUIRK
IN A SECOND BY MISS EGGMAN.
OKAY SO THIS IS A SIMPLE BUT
IMPORTANT MEASURE IT IT IS
BASED ON THAT'S CURRENT LAW IN
A NUMBER OF OTHER STATES. THAT
BASICALLY **** TO PHASE OUT
NATURAL LATEX GLOVES IN
RESTAURANTS OTHER FOOD
FACILITIES BECAUSE OF THE HIGH
INCIDENCES. OF ALLERGIES THAT
ARE ACTUALLY LIFE THREATENING
IN MANY CASES AND THE FACT THAT
THERE IS LESS EXPENSIVE LESS
TOXIC LESS PROBLEMATIC
ALTERNATIVES THAT ARE OUT
THERE. WE'RE PROUD TO HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO PULL TOGETHER A LOT OF
SUPPORT IN THIS BILL INCLUDING
THE VERY FOLKS WHO ARE
REGULATED UNDER THE BILL. AND
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR A VOTE. SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT.
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE FINANCE
NEUTRONS MEASURE THANK YOU YOU
LIKE CLOSE RESPECT RESTAURANT
THANK YOU HAD AN INFLUENCE A
ROLL CALL WITH MR OBERNOLTE NOT
VOTING THANK YOU SENATOR ALLEN
THANK YOU SO MUCH A MANAGER
MEMBERS THANK YOU THANK YOU AT
THIS POINT IN AND I APOLOGIZE
TO CENTERS HAVE BEEN WAITING MR
GABRIEL NEEDS LEAVING HE'S
PRESENTING ON BEHALF OF MISS
RUBIO SO WE'RE GONNA LET HIM
PRESENT VERY QUICKLY ON SB SIX
EIGHTY SEVEN ENJOYS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION I HAVE A MOTION
BY MS CARILLO. A SECOND BY
DOCTOR QUIRK YOU MAY PROCEED MR
GABRIEL. COURTESY OUT PLEASE
TODAY TO PRESENT. SB SIX EIGHT
SEVEN ON BEHALF OF SENATOR
RUBIO WOULD INCREASE THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF. CALIFORNIA'S
HOMELESSNESS POLICY BY
INCLUDING VETERANS COLLEGE
STUDENTS AND PARENTS WITH LIVE
HOMELESS EXPERIENCE ON THE
STATE'S. HOMELESS COORDINATING
AND FINANCING COUNSEL
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU ARE THERE
SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT. GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
FAMILY GIVES REPRESENTING THE
LOS ANGELES COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION WE APPRECIATE THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS AND WE URGE
YOUR AYE VOTE FOR THE BILL.
THANK YOU. JUST ABOUT THE
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY IN SUPPORT. FIGURE
THEIR SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
SEE NINE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
FINANCE. CONSUMER SERVICES AND
HOUSING AGENCY ESTIMATES COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH THE SPELL OR
BETWEEN FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
AND A HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS
AND ALL OBSERVABLE WITHIN
CURRENT RESOURCES ANY REQUESTS
FOR ADDITIONAL RESOURCES WILL
BE VALUED AS PART OF THE ANNUAL
BUDGET PROCESS. ALRIGHT WITH
THAT THANK IT'S OUT WITH THE
REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING AND
MISTER DO YOU HAVE A MISTER
OBERNOLTE VOTING AYE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU NOW THAT
MISTER CALDERON IS HERE WE CAN
DISPENSE OF SB FORTY FIVE IT BY
MISTER BELL THAT GETS OUT ON A
B. ROLL CALL. WITH MISTER
MAIENSCHEIN NOT VOTING. MOVING
ON MISTER TADO. MR TADO. IT
LOOKS LIKE YOU ARE PRESENTING
ON A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE SB FIVE
FIFTY NINE THAT IS CORRECT A
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME
HERE TODAY I'M HERE TO PRESENT
SB FIVE FIVE NINE SB FIVE FIVE
NINE IS A DISTRICT BILL THAT
AIMS TO ADDRESS WATER SUPPLY
AND SUBSIDENCE PROBLEMS IN THE
SOUTHERN CENTRAL VALLEY BY
REPAIRING THE CRUMBLING FIND
KERN CANAL. OTHER CANALS A
MAJOR WATERY DELIVERY SYSTEM
THAT STRETCHES A HUNDRED FIFTY
TWO MILES LONG AND CURRY'S
WATER FROM FRESNO TO
BAKERSFIELD IT IS INCREDIBLY
VITAL TO THE LOCAL ECONOMY OF
THE COMMUNITIES IN THE
SURROUNDING REGION AND IN MY
DISTRICT BUILT IN THE MID
NINETEEN HUNDREDS AND HAS LOST
60% OF ITS CONVEYANCE CAPACITY
THIS CANAL NOT REPAIRED
JEOPARDIZES THE QUALITY OF LIFE
IN THE REGION OF THE BILL WAS
AMENDED TO MAKE FUNDING FOR THE
BILL UPON AN APPROPRIATION FROM
THE LEGISLATURE AND ALSO INPUTS
FISCAL AND POLICY OVERSIGHT.
THEBILL IN FRONT OF YOU TO
DATE A SIMPLY SET UP THE POLICY
FRAMEWORK FOR WHEN FUNDING FOR
THE PROJECT IS SECURED THIS
BILL HAS RECEIVED BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT INCLUDING FROM OUR
REGION'S LOCAL CONGRESSIONAL
REPRESENTATIVES AND IS CO
AUTHORED BY THE ENTIRE SOUTHERN
CENTRAL VALLEY DELEGATION THE
FRANKLIN CANAL FORMS PART OF
CALIFORNIA'S WATER
INFRASTRUCTURE BACKBONE A
REPAIRING IT IS CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT TO MEET THE STATE'S
GROUNDWATER SUSTAINABILITY IN
CLEAN DRINKING WATER GOALS. AND
I JUST WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION. AS YOU KNOW
FOR THE SUSPENSE CANDIDATE SO
BIG. THANK YOU SPEAKERS IN
SUPPORT. THANK CURRENTLY UNDER
THE FRESNO TULARE AND KERN
COUNTY SUPERVISORS ON SUPPORT
TODAY THANK YOU THANK YOU
DIGITAL SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT.
ALEX BEING WITH A FRIEND WATER
THIRTY IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION. SEE
NINE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
FINANCE AS OPPOSED TO THIS
MEASURE BECAUSE THE RESULT N
SIGNIFICANT GENERAL FUND COST
PRESSURES OF FOUR HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS THE DEPARTMENT
OF WATER RESOURCES KNOWS THAT
WOULD SERVE AS A PASS THROUGH
FOR THE GRANT FUNDING AS TO ME
THAT ANY CONTRACTING COSTS
WOULD BE MINOR OBSERVABLE.
THANK YOU TO WORK AS A QUESTION.
SO THIS SAID DOESN'T SET UP THE
FUNDING PER SE IT JUST SETS UP
A PROCESS IN MY GETTING THAT
RIGHT THAT IS CORRECT IT'S A
IT'S A FRAMEWORK IN YOUR HOPING
TO GET THE MONEY FROM PERHAPS
IN NO THE BOND FOR THE RUN.
WERE LIVING AT OPENED TO
FIGURING OUT OF THE LEGISLATURE
TO FUND THAT IN THE NEAR FUTURE
OKAY. LET ME SAY I THE FRANK
CANAL NEEDS TO BE FIXED.
THERE'S NO DOUBT THAT
ORDINARILY THESE THINGS ARE
PAID FOR BY THE USERS. WHAT
MAKES THIS DIFFERENT. SITTING
THE USERS HAVE BEEN YOU KNOW
PAYING FOR IT OVER THIS TIME
AND- IT'S REALLY. IT'S ABOUT
PROVIDING YOU KNOW CLEAN
DRINKING WATER AND SHATTERED
AND MEETING ALL THE GOALS THAT
WE NEED TO MEET IN THE VALLEY.
NO BUT THIS IS PART OF THE
FEDERAL PROJECT AS WELL FEDERAL
WATER PROJECT. YES SO THOSE
RATES OF ON WATER ARE THE
LOWEST. BY FAR IN THE STATE. I
WOULD THINK THAT GIVEN THE LOW
RATES THAT ARE PAID FOR BY THE
PEOPLE IN THE FEDERAL PROJECT.
THAT YOU COULD AT LEAST YEAH
I'VE MATCH MONEY FROM THE STATE
THAT'S MY COMMENT THANK THANK
YOU. THIS BILL DOES MOVE TO
SUSPENSE WOULD YOU LOOK. LIKE
ANY CLOSING COMMENTS SIR. NO
JUST THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO THINK OF IT
THANK YOU CENTER TYLER. MISTER
MCGUIRE. MISTER MCGUIRE. YOU'LL
BE PRESENTING ON SB THREE SEVEN
SEVEN ENJOY THE TO PASS
RECOMMENDATION. A MOTION BY MS
CREO SECOND BY MISTER EGGMAN
SECOND I'M SORRY I'M SORRY.
GOING TO QUICK MISTER MCGUIRE
THANK YOU SO MUCH MANAGER GOOD
MORNING THE MORNING COMMITTEE
OF THE VERY QUICK MADAM CHAIR
LONG STORY SHORT TO CLEAN UP TO
A PREVIOUS SENATE BILL THAT
PROTECTS POSSES FROM LONG
LASTING SIDE EFFECTS FROM OVER
PRESCRIBING. IT'S GONNA REQUIRE
THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL TO INCLUDE
IN THEIR PSYCH MED FORMS A
REQUEST FOR AUTHORIZATION OF
THE RELEASE OF MEDICAL
INFORMATION WITHIN WORKING
COLLABORATIVELY WITH THEM AND
WE'VE ALSO COMMITTED TO
TECHNICAL MINUTES ON THE FLOOR
WOULD RESPECTFULLY
ASTRONOMICAL. THANK YOU
SPEAKERS AS PART THE JENNIFER
SOMOS WITH THE MEDICAL BOARD OF
CALIFORNIA THE BOARDS PLEASED
TO SUPPORT THIS IMPORTANT
CONSUMER PROTECTION BILL AND WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST DRIVE UP
THANK YOU THANK YOU ADDITIONAL
SPEAKERS AND SUPPORT. SPEAKERS
IN OPPOSITION. DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. FINANCES ARE HAVE A
POSITION AT THIS TIME THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL THE DEPARTMENT
OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES EACH EXPECT THE BILL
TO RESULT IN ONLY MINOR
OBSERVABLE FISCAL IMPACTS. THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
TO NOT HAVE A COMPLETE PHYSICAL
ESTIMATE ON THE BILL AT THIS
TIME BUT ANTICIPATES NEEDING
AUTHORITY FOR ONE LIMITED TERM
POSITION THROUGH THE JUNE
THIRTIETH TWENTY TWENTY. TO
CONVENE A WORKGROUP WITH
SPECIFIED STAKEHOLDERS. THANK
YOU WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE THANK
UNITED AMENDMENT FOR THE
WORKGROUP WAS A REQUEST THAT
WAS MADE TO US SO WITH RESPECT
LAST NIGHT THOUGH. THANK YOU
THAT GETS OUT ON A ROLL CALL
THINKING IS REQUIRE. THE
MANAGER I THINK WE HAD I
APOLOGIZE AND GIVE ONE EIGHTY
FIVE AND SIX THREE SEVEN. AS
WELL. THOSE ARE CONSENT YOU
COULD PRESENT ON BUT THERE
AGAIN PERFECT THANK YOU SO YOU
KNOW IT'S ALL GOOD. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ENTERED THINKING YES.
WITH THAT MISTER CHILL. MR TO
THIS IS AN AC ARE ONE OH FIVE
IT ENJOYS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION. THE MOTION BY
MS CREEL AS SECOND BY DOCTOR
EGGMAN. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
THIS IS RESOLUTION THAT
ENCOURAGES OUR GOVERNOR TO
ENGAGE WITH THE STATES OF
WASHINGTON AND OREGON WHO WISH
TO PARTNER WITH US TO LOWER
PRESCRIPTION DRUG PRICES ACROSS
OUR REGION WITH NEGLIGIBLE COST
OF THE STATE. AND RESPECTFULLY
ASK FROM ABOUT. THANK YOU
SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT. SPEAKERS
IN OPPOSITION. IN A FINANCE NO
FILE. THANK YOU. SEEN NO SO.
SPEAKER IS I'M TRYING TO GIVE A
FEW MINUTES WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT
THANK YOU THAT COULD THAT WITH
REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING MR GAP
AND MISTER OBERNOLTE VOTING I
THANK YOU. DOCTOR PAN. DOCTOR
PAN IT LOOKS LIKE SB THREE
FORTY THREE IS WHAT YOU'LL BE
PRESENTING READY TO PASS
RECOMMENDATION RIGHT NOW I'M
WAITING PRESENTATION ON THE
REST OF THE BILLS A MOTION BY A
MISS KOREA CARILLO IN A SECOND
MY DOCTOR QUIRK EXCELLENT THANK
YOU SB THREE FORTY THREE
REMOVES PROVISIONS IN THE LAW
THAT ALLOWS KAISER PERMANENTE
TO REPORT LESS INFORMATION TO
REGULATORS AND OTHER HEALTH
PLANS AND HOSPITALS IN THE
ASSEMBLY HEALTH COMMITTEE
AGREED TO AMENDMENTS TO ADDRESS
SOME OF CRISIS CONCERNS WE DID
AGREE TO REINSTATE THE KAISER
LANGUAGE TO ALLOW THEM TO
REPORT BALANCE SHEET AND CASH
FLOW STATEMENTS AS A GROUP.
KAISER ALSO REQUESTED DELAYED
IMPLEMENTATION DATE FOR
RECORDED APARTMENT REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS UNTIL HOTSPOT
CHANGES ASSISTANT ALLOWED ME
REPORTING HOWEVER ALL OTHER
HOSPITALS IN CALIFORNIA
REQUIRED TO REPORT THIS
INFORMATION MANUALLY AND WE
FELT IT WAS UNFAIR TO ALLOW
KAISER TO CONTINUE TO AVOID A
REPORTING REQUIREMENT THAT WE
REQUIRE EVERYONE ELSE TO DO. SO
WHAT THAT RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE AND I HAVE
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND TEA OR
ON BEHALF OF THE SERVICE
EMPLOYEES INTERNATIONAL UNION
I'LL KEEP IT PRETTY BASIC AND
STRAIGHT FORWARD WE WANT TO
ADDRESS HEALTH CARE COST ACROSS
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. THE
ONLY WAY FOR YOU AS LAWMAKERS
TO BE ABLE TO DO THAT IS TO
HAVE A TRANSPARENT. PROCESS
WITH TRANSPARENT INFORMATION ON
WHAT'S DRIVING HEALTH CARE COST
ALL HOSPITALS HAVE TO PROVIDE
THAT INFORMATION. HOPEFULLY WE
EMBARK ON THIS NEXT YEAR AND
REALLY TACKLE HEALTHCARE COSTS
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
THIS BILL WOULD GIVE US THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SEE WHAT'S
DRIVING ANSWERS COST IT'S RISEN
11% OVER THE LAST THREE YEARS.
THEY MAKE UP 65% OF THE MARKET
WE BELIEVE THIS INFORMATION IS
POWER THERE'S A SMALL COST OF A
HUNDRED AND TWENTY THOUSAND.
ARE SOME ODD DOLLARS FOR THE
INCREASE STAFF AT OFSTED TO
OVERSEE THE INFORMATION THEY'RE
GOING TO GAIN WE BELIEVE THAT'S
A MODEST INVESTMENT FOR.
HOPEFULLY. HE TO RETURN ON
TRANSPARENCY TO ADDRESS COST
ACROSS THE STATE. ADDITIONAL
SUPPORT GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS JUST MEAN PALETTE
FOR HELP ACCESS CALIFORNIA THE
STATE WIDE HEALTH CARE CONSUMER
ADVOCACY COALITION HERE IN
SUPPORT OF SB THREE FORTY THREE
WHERE IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
FOR THE REASONS THAT. MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SCO YOU
MENTIONED. HEALTHAXIS SUPPORTS
LEGISLATION TO IMPROVE
TRANSPARENCY AND REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS IN THE HEALTHCARE
INDUSTRY. IN ORDER TO TACKLE
THE ISSUE OF RISING HEALTHCARE
COSTS THERE MUST BE TRANSPARENT
COMPREHENSIVE AND COMPATIBLE
DATA THROUGHOUT THE SYSTEM. IN
ORDER TO COME UP WITH EVIDENCE
BASED SOLUTIONS THE BILL WOULD
BE FINANCED BY LICENSING FEES
AND PET PAID BY THE HOSPITALS
AND HEALTH PLANS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ARE THERE SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION. I'M SORRY DIGITAL
SUPPORTERS SEE NINE SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS THERESA STARK
WITH KAISER PERMANENTE A WE ARE
AND FORCEFULLY STILL AND I'M
HOSE UNLESS AMENDED POSITION WE
DO APPRECIATE THE AMENDMENTS AT
THE AUTHOR AND SPONSOR HAVE
AGREED TO SO FAR WHICH HAVE
ALMOST RESULT ALL OF OUR
CONCERNS WE ARE SIMPLY
REQUESTING ONE ADDITIONAL
AMENDMENT FOR A DELAYED
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE VERY
SIGNIFICANT NEWARK REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS WE HAVE AGREED TO
DO. AT A FACILITY LEVEL WE ARE
NOT EXEMPT RIGHT NOW WE ARE
DOING THESE REPORTS ON A
REGIONAL BASIS WE HAVE AGREED
TO DO THEM ON THE FACILITY PER
HOSPITAL BASIS BUT THAT'S GONNA
BE THIRTY FOUR NEW REPORTS FOUR
TIMES A YEAR OUR SPOT IS
INTENDING TO UPDATE THEIR
TECHNOLOGY AND HAVE THE ABILITY
TO DO THIS AND AN ELECTRONIC
UPLOAD FASHION IN EIGHTEEN
MONTHS AND WE'RE SIMPLY ASKING
FOR THAT DELAY. SO THAT WE CAN
DO THIS IN A COST EFFECTIVE
FASHION SO WE'RE A LITTLE
PERPLEXED AS TO WHY THAT
AMENDMENT IS NOT BEING RECEIVED
WE WOULD GO NEUTRAL WITH WITH
THAT LANGUAGE IN CONTINUE TO
REQUEST THAT VERY REASONABLE
DELAYED IMPLEMENTATION FROM A
FISCAL PERSPECTIVE I WOULD ALSO
NOTE ON THE HEALTH PLAN SIDE OF
THIS BILL BECAUSE THIS WILL
ACTUALLY CHANGE HOW WE FILE OUR
RATES WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
MANAGED HEALTHCARE. IT WILL
ACTUALLY CHANGE HOW WE BUILD
OUR RATES WITH OUR LARGE
CUSTOMERS AND ACTUALLY COULD
RECALL I RESULT IN A REPEAT
INCREASE FOR SOME OF OUR PUBLIC
SECTOR ACCOUNTS LIKE CALPERS
AND LARGE A PUBLIC SECTOR
COUNTY CITY THAT SAT AROUND WE
HAVE ADVISE THE AUTHOR THAT IT
COULD CHANGE HOW WE BUILD OUR
RATES AND RESULT IN RATE
INCREASES WHICH- I WILL HAVE A
CERTAINLY A FISCAL IMPACT ON
THOSE PUBLIC ENTITIES. SO WITH
THAT WE CONTINUE TO REQUEST THE
DELAYED IMPLEMENTATION. BUT
APPRECIATE ALL THE WORK OF THE
AUTHOR SO FAR. THANK YOU
ADDITIONAL OPPOSITION
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. THE
OFFICE OF STATEWIDE HEALTH
PLANNING AND DEVELOPMENT
ESTIMATES SYBIL LIKELY RESULT
IN COST OF ONE HUNDRED NINETEEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS FROM THE
CALIFORNIA HEALTH DATA AND
PLANNING FUND AND ONE POSITION
BEGINNING IN TWENTY TWENTY
TWENTY ONE AND HUNDRED AND
SEVEN THOUSAND DOLLARS IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO AN
ONGOING THE DEPARTMENT OF
MANAGED HEALTH CARE AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE NOT
DISPUTE A FISCAL IMPACT OR A
FISCAL IMPACT WILL BE MINOR AND
AFFORDABLE WHAT IS POSSIBLE
THAT THE MEDI CAL HEALTH PLANS
REQUIREMENT TO COMPLY WITH THIS
BILL MAY RESULT IN COST. THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES DID NOT ANTICIPATE
HAVE A PHYSICAL IMPACT AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU WHICH I CLOSED
AFTER HIM I CERTAINLY
ASTRONOMICAL THANK YOU TAKE IT
OUT ON B. ROLL CALL. WITH MR
TAMBOURINE AYE THANK YOU THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR COMMITTEE. IS
CHIANG. MS CHANG YOU WILL BE
PRESENTING ON SB SIXTY FOUR IT
ENJOYS A DO PASS AS AMENDED
RECOMMENDATION THE AMENDMENT IS
TO LOWER THE CIVIL PENALTY AND
CLARIFY THE RESPONSIBILITY OF
THE SHELTER AND OWNER OF THE
ANIMAL AND THAT LOWERED PENALTY
WOULD BE I THINK WE AGREED ON A
HUNDRED DOLLARS TO ACCEPT THOSE
MOMENTS. GREAT YOU MAY PROCEED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISS MADAM
CHAIRWOMAN MOVIES I DON'T. THE
MEASURE MY NETWORK A SECOND
TIME IS CREEL THANK YOU I WILL
BE TAKING THE AMENDMENTS SB
SIXTY FOUR REQUIRES ANIMAL
SHELTERS TO MICROCHIP ANY DOG
OR CAT THAT IS EITHER DROPPED
OR CLAIM BY A PET OWNER THIS
WILL ULTIMATELY SAVE TAXPAYER
DOLLARS AND LIVES BY
SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCING THE
AMOUNT OF EUTHANIZING SHELTER
DOGS AND CATS. AND WE GOT WITH
YOUR PERMISSION I'D LIKE TO
TURN IT OVER TO MY WITNESSES
HERE NICOLAS ACTIVE FROM SOCIAL
COMPASSION LEGISLATION CAN ALL
TEAM FROM SACRAMENTO SPCA I DO
I DO WANT TO I KNOW THIS IS A
LOT OF POLICY IN THIS BILL SO
WE CAN IF WE CAN MAKE SURE THAT
WE TALK JUST TO THE FINANCIAL
ASPECTS. AND YOU HAVE TWO
MINUTES GREAT THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR OF MY NAME IS NICOLAS
SACKETT SOCIAL COMPASSION
LEGISLATION PROUD SPONSOR OF
THE BILL JUST WANT TO SAY THANK
YOU FOR WORKING WITH US TO GET
THE BILL OUT OF THE COMMITTEE.
MAYBE AND- LET EVERYONE KNOW
THAT WE'RE STILL KILLING
HUNDREDS OF THOUSAND DOLLARS IN
CALIFORNIA AND CATS AND OUR
GOAL IS TO REDUCE THE NUMBER
AND THIS BILL STEP THING. GOING
TO DO THAT NOW. YES WE ARE
ABOUT. THANK YOU. ADDITIONAL
SUPPORTERS THANK YOU MA'AM. MY
NAME IS COLONEL TEEN ON THE C.
E. O. OF THE SACRAMENTO SPCA
WORKING CLOSELY WITH ANIMAL
CONTROL IN DALLAS WHICH
INSTITUTED A MANDATORY MICRO
CHIPPING THEY FOUND SIGNIFICANT
SAVINGS IN BOTH THEIR
EUTHANASIA MATERIALS WHEN YOU
INJECT AN ANIMAL THERE IS COSTS
THERE'S CLASSES BECAUSE OF THE
ANIMAL THEY FOUND THAT THE
MICROCHIP IN COST WERE OFFSET
BY THE FEES CHARGED TO THE
PUBLIC FOR THAT MY COULD
SHIPPING SERVICE. ALSO GREATLY
REDUCE COSTS IN THE NUMBER OF
ANIMALS ENTERING THEIR SHELTERS
WHICH REDUCE THE CARE COSTS AS
WELL AS A GREAT INCREASE IN THE
RETURN TO FIELD WHICH CAUGHT
THE ANIMALS OUT OF THE SHELTER
BACK IN THEIR HOMES WITHOUT
EVER COMING BACK TO THE MAIN SO
THEY WHEN I ASKED HIM WHAT THEY
READ TO FIGHT AGAIN TO GET THIS
PAST IS MANDATORY MICROCHIP
AND- THEY WERE 1000% BEHIND
THAT BECAUSE OF. THE COST
SAVINGS THAT THEY SAW.
WONDERFUL. ADDITIONAL
SUPPORTERS. JOHN SINCLAIR ABOUT
FOR THE COUNTY SAN DIEGO IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU A SPEAKERS
IN OPPOSITION SEE NUMBER
DEPARTMENT FINANCE. WE HAVE NOT
HAD A CHANCE TO LOOK AT THE
CURRENT AMENDMENTS BUT WE ARE
NEUTRAL ON THE BILL IT'S IN
PRINT. THANK YOU. SUCH WORK.
WHAT IS THE COST OF MICROCHIP
IN THAT A CONSUMER MIGHT HAVE
TO PAY WHEN THEY ARE ADOPTING A
DOG. IT REALLY DEPENDS. THE
CLASSES LIKE WITH THE COST OF
MY CHRISTMAS FIVE DOLLARS. YEAH
BUT HOW MUCH IS MICROCHIP AND
COST THE MACHINES THAT TIME.
IT'S MORE THAN TEN DOLLARS BUT
I DON'T KNOW HOW MUCH IT IS A
LESS THAN ONE MINUTE PROCEDURE
DONE BY A NON CERTIFIED
PROFESSIONAL IT INVOLVES A
MICROCHIP THOSE ALREADY
IMPLANTED IN THE DISPENSER
DISPENSER GHOST PENSION. IN AND
YOU'RE DONE SO IT IS ACTUALLY
LESS THAN FIVE DOLLARS TO MP TO
INJECTED INCLUDING STAFF COSTS
AND THE COST IN THE LIST OF THE
MICROCHIP IS FIVE DOLLARS SO IT
IS EASILY LESS THAN A DOLLAR SO
ORDINARILY THEY'D BE PAYING
TANNER MAYBE SLIGHTLY MORE SB
SAY WE CHARGE THIRTY FIVE
DOLLARS MOST VENTS CARRIAGE
UPWARD OF THAT. OKAY. SO BE
ABOVE THIRTY FIVE DOLLARS. IT'S
CERTAINLY A GOOD IDEA ONE OF
THE PROBLEMS WE HAVE IN. THIS
BILL WON'T SOLVE IT IS THAT
PEOPLE DON'T UPDATE THOSE CHIPS
AND SO A LOT OF. DOGS THAT ARE
STRAYS. YOU'LL FIND THAT THE
ORIGINAL OWNER NO LONGER OWNS
AND THEN THE CHIP PASSING AND-
UPDATED THAT MAYBE SOMETHING
FOR NEXT YEAR I DON'T KNOW WHAT
YOU CAN DO ABOUT IT IT'S JUST A
THOUGHT. THANK YOU. WOULD LIKE
TO CLOSE. WITH THAT I JUST
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY VOTE.
THANK YOU AND THAT GETS OUT ON
A ROLL CALL THANK YOU MISTER.
MR NIELSEN. NIELSEN IT LOOKS
LIKE HE'LL BE PRESENTING ON SB
SEVENTY IT ENJOYS A DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO DELETE SECTION ONE
OF THE BILL THE FINDINGS AND
DECLARATIONS GIVES UP THOSE
AMENDMENTS THANK YOU NICK THEY
WILL BE ACCEPTED THANK YOU SIR
SECOND WAS MOVED BY MISS
CARILLO AND SECOND BY DOCTOR
QUICK ME PROCEED. MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS THIS ADDRESSES.
ISSUE THAT'S. COME TO OUR
ATTENTION WITH THESE CHARACTER
PRESIDENT FIRES THAT WE'VE HAD
TO DEAL WITH. IT REQUIRES AN
ELECTRICAL CORPORATION TO
INCLUDE IN ITS WILDLIFE AND
WILD FIRE MITIGATION PLAN. AND
NOT A NOTE I CONSIDER INCLUDE
WILD LIFE BECAUSE THEY ARE
AFFECTED BY THESE FIRES TO.
THEY WOULD HAVE TO CONSIDER
UNDERGROUND ELECTRICAL
DISTRIBUTION LINES ALSO IN THE
AREAS THAT ARE OF THE HIGHEST
RISK. THE PROBLEM THAT WE'VE
HAD MOST OFTEN HAS BEEN ABOVE
GROUND TRANSMISSION. LIGHTS
SELLER THESE TOWERS. THAT HAVE
STARTED THESE FIRES. AND UNDER
GROUNDING IS A MORE SECURE WAY
TO DO IT AND WE'RE SIMPLY
ASKING THAT THEY WOULD EXAMINE.
AND REPORT AND PURSUE THAT
OPTION IF IT IS APPLICATIONS.
THE RESIDENTS TO CALIFORNIA I
THINK WOULD RATHER SEE THIS OF
THE PUBLIC NOW HAS BECOME MORE
ACUTELY AWARE OF THESE. ABOVE
GROUND. SOURCES OF THE FIRES.
AND THEY'RE CONCERNED ABOUT.
AND IT'S CERTAINLY NOT WITHOUT
WOOD WHO GOES WITHOUT SAYING
THAT THE F. B. ELECTRICAL
COMPANIES DO NEED TO HARDEN
THEIR- DELIVERY SYSTEMS. THE
REFERENCE CHECKS YOUR. AND THIS
IS A GOOD WAY TO DO IT. WE NEED
TO UNDERSTAND THAT THE COSTS
ARE OF SOME CONSIDERATION. BUT
THE COST OF THESE DEVASTATING
FIRES. OUR OF MORE
CONSIDERATION AND THE JEOPARDY
OF LIFE'S THE PROPERTY. AND
SOCIETAL COST. A GREATER. RATE
PAYERS ARE ALREADY BEARING THE
BURDEN OF SOME OF THE IN
ATTENTION OVER THE DECADES. AND
WE NEED TO TAKE STEPS TO
MINIMIZE THAT IN THE FUTURE.
UNDER GROUNDING IS NOT JUST AN
INVESTMENT IN A RELIABLE
INFRASTRUCTURE BUT IT IS
INVESTMENT IN THE LIVES. AND
AVOIDED COSTS WHICH IS A BIG
ISSUE AND ELECTRICAL DRUG
DELIVERY. WE WANT TO ENCOURAGE
UTILITIES TO TAKE THESE ACTIONS
THE PART OF THE ONGOING PLAN.
TO HARDEN AND GREATER PROTECT
US. IN OUR COMMUNITIES FROM
THESE DEVASTATING FIRES I WOULD
ASK AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU ARE
THERE SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT.
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. FINANCE
OPPOSED TO THE BILL AS
CURRENTLY IN PRINT UNLESS IT IS
AMENDED BECAUSE OF CONFLICTS
WITH THE BROADER LEGISLATIVE
PACKAGE THAT THE LEGISLATURE
AND THE GOVERNOR HAVE ALREADY
APPROVED WITH ONE EXCEPTION ITS
PROVISIONS ARE DUPLICATIVE OF
AB TEN FIFTY FOUR AND AB ONE
ELEVEN ALMOST IS DUPLICATIVE
PROVISIONS REMOVED THIS BILL
RESULT AND STATUTORY COMPLEX
ABOUT WHICH ENTITIES
RESPONSIBLE REVIEWING WILDFIRE
MEDICATION PLANS. THANK YOU.
WITH THAT I'LL TAKE THAT AS
YOUR CLOTHES IS THAT ALRIGHT
INDEED THAT GETS OUT ON A ROLL
CALL THANK YOU MISTER NIELSEN.
THANK YOU THE BILL IS OUT MR
MULLIN LOOKS LIKE YOUR NEXT I
TOLD YOU BEFORE TEN NINE C. I
LIED I'M SORRY. MR ALL YEAR IS
YOURS IS A LAST ACA THAT WE ARE
AVOIDING SENDING TO ON SUSPENSE
IT'S ACA FOR ENJOYS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION I'M PROUD TO BE
A CO AUTHOR YOU MAY PROCEED. WE
HAVE A MOTION BY DOCTOR EGGMAN
A SECOND BY MISS CARILLO. THANK%
YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
PRESENTING A CAFOR WHICH TAKES
A SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT APPROACH.
THAN MR LOW'S MEASURE WHICH YOU
HEARD EARLIER TODAY. AC FOUR
WOULD CREATE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
ENGAGE FIRST TIME VOTERS AND
ENCOURAGE YOUTH VOTER
PARTICIPATION. BY ALLOWING
SEVENTEEN YEAR OLDS TO VOTE IN
THE PRIMARY ELECTION PROVIDED
THEY WILL BE EIGHTEEN. BY THE
GENERAL ELECTION THE IDEA IS
NOT A NEW ONE NEARLY HALF OF
STATES IN THE U. S. ALREADY
ALLOW SEVENTEEN YEAR OLDS. TO
PARTICIPATE IN PRIMARIES AND
CAUCUSES. FIRST TIME VOTER
SHOULD HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
HAVE A SAY AND PARTICIPATE IN A
FULL ELECTION YCLE. ILLINOIS
INDIANA KENTUCKY MISSISSIPPI
OHIO IN SOUTH CAROLINA ARE JUST
A FEW THE STATE'S ALREADY AHEAD
OF CALIFORNIA ON THIS ISSUE AS
YOU KNOW A CA FOR. WE HAVE TO
BE APPROVED BY THE VOTERS OF
CALIFORNIA I THINK YOU'LL BE
PALATABLE TO THE ELECTORATE I'M
HOPEFUL THAT THIS APPROACH WILL
BE EMBRACED. BY VOTERS WE DO
HAVE THE SECRETARY STATE OUT TO
BE A SUPPORTING OUR APPROACH TO
THE SEVENTEEN YEAR OLD VOTE.
PROUD TO HAVE HIS SUPPORT AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR EITHER.
THANK YOU SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT.
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE FINANCES
NEUTRAL ON THIS MEASURE BUT
NOTES CONCERNS THAT THE BILL
WILL INCREASE COSTS FOR THE
SECRETARY OF STATE TO PRINT
IMELDA TIONAL VOTING MATERIALS
TO THE MEASURE BE PASSED THE
SECRETARY STATE ESTIMATES
ADDITIONAL ONE TIME COSTS OF A
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS GENERAL FUND
IN FISCAL YEAR TWENTY TWENTY TO
TWENTY ONE TO UPDATE
INFORMATION PRINTED DOCUMENTS
AND ON WEBSITES AND OTHER
VARIOUS COSTS IN THE RANGE OF.
THIRTY THREE POINT FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS TO SEVENTY
EIGHT POINT FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS AND REQUEST FOR
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES OF SUBJECT
TO REVIEW AND APPROVAL TO THE
ANNUAL BUDGET PROCESS. THANK
YOU THANK YOU FOR THE SUPPORT
BILL THAT GETS OUT ON A BE ROLL
CALL WITH MR YEP THIRTEEN I AM
MISTER MEAN TRYING NOT VOTING.
THANK YOU. MS GALGIANI. LAST
BUT CERTAINLY NOT LEAST I DON'T
KNOW. OKAY I SB SIX THIRTY I'M
SORRY FIVE NINETY ONE GETTING
OLD SUCKS. DO PASS. IT WAS THE
PAST RECOMMENDATIONS THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS AS THE FIVE
NINETY ONE AUTHORIZES A
PRACTICING PSYCHIATRIST OR
PSYCHOLOGIST FROM THE STATE
DEPARTMENT OF STATE HOSPITALS
ARE THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION TO HAVE PROMPT
AND UNIMPEDED ACCESS TO AN
INMATE WHO IS TEMPORARILY HOUSE
A COUNTY CORRECTIONAL FACILITY
A COUNTY MEDICAL FACILITY OR A
STATE ASSIGNED MENTAL HEALTH
PROVIDERS THE BILL HAS MINOR
COSTA COUNTY JAILS AND NO
ADDITIONAL COST TO CDC ARE OR
STATE HOSPITALS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR IDOL. THAT HAS A
MOTION BUT AFTER QUIRK IN THE
SECOND BY MISS CREO SPEAKERS IN
SUPPORT. HE FOR THE RECORD ONLY
A GRIPPING WITH THE AMERICAN
FEDERATION OF STATE COUNTY
MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES COUNCIL
FIFTY SEVEN WE ARE AN AFFILIATE
OF ASKING CALIFORNIA WHO IS A
SPONSOR OF THIS BILL WE HAD AN
OPPORTUNITY TO REVIEW THE
ANALYSIS THAT WAS DONE AGREE
WITH THE STATED FISCAL EFFECTS
WE REPRESENT MEMBERS WITHIN THE
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF STATE HOSPITALS
WHO DO THESE EVALUATION WE
THINK THAT THIS SMALL
INVESTMENT IS WORTH THE GOAL
MEETING THE GOAL OF PROVIDING
FALLING COMPLETES. EVALUATIONS
AND. WE HOPE THAT THIS CAN BE
DONE IN A TIMELY MANNER THANK
YOU. THANK YOU ADDITIONAL
SUPPORTERS. MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
IS COMMITTEE BY NELSON ON
BEHALF TO MARK AND FEDERATION
OF STATE COUNTY MUNICIPAL
EMPLOYEES SPONSORED A BILL. IN
STRONG OBVIOUSLY HERE OF
BELIEVE THAT THIS IS THE
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT MEASURE
AND WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE CONSULTANT FOR THEIR
PROVED ANALYSIS ON THE BILL. IT
FOR THE REASONS PREVIOUSLY
STATED BY MY COLLEAGUE MISS
GRIFFIN WILL COST FIFTY SEVEN
WITH A STRONGLY. SUPPLY URGE
YOUR SUPPORT FOR THIS PIECE OF
LEGISLATION. ADDITIONAL
SUPPORTERS. SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. FINANCES OPPOSED TO
THIS MEASURE BECAUSE IT COULD
RESULT IN THE STATE
REIMBURSABLE MANDATE INCREASING
NUMBER OF PRISONERS WHO ARE
COMMITTED TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
STATE HOSPITALS AS MENTALLY
DISORDERED OFFENDERS RESULTING
IN SIGNIFICANT GENERAL FUND
COST PRESSURES AND INCREASE THE
NUMBER OF MDOC CHALLENGER
COMMITMENTS IN SUPERIOR COURT.
THANK YOU. WOULD YOU LIKE
CLOSER. WHAT SORRY MR BIGELOW
HAS A QUESTION. TO THE AUTHOR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IT'S A GOOD
BILL WE'RE HERE TO SUPPORT IT
TODAY BUT I DID WANT TO GET
CLARIFICATION ON PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS ARE YOU GOING TO BE
TAKING SOME PROPOSED AMENDMENTS
ON THE FLOOR. YES WE ARE OKAY
JUST PACIFIC LEAD TO ADD
SECTION THREE THOUSAND THREE E.
TWO REGARDING. REGARDING
TUBERCULOSIS TESTING. YES.
THANK YOU I JUST WANNA MAKE
SURE WE'RE CLEAR ON THAT. GOT
IT RECORDED. THANK YOU. WITH
THAT WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL THANK
YOU THAT GETS OUT ON A ROLL
CALL THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT AT
THIS POINT IF WE CAN GET A
MOTION ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
A MOTION BY MS CARILLO AS
SECOND BY DOCTOR QUIRK MA'AM
SECRETARY HE READ THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. IS YOUR EIGHTY SEVEN
AC ART WELL TO SB 213-912-8130
415-115-6160 FIVE ONE EIGHTY
FIVE ONE NINETY SEVEN. TWO
THIRTY FOUR TO THIRTY FIVE TO
FORTY TO FORTY NINE TO SIXTY
SEVEN TO EIGHTY SIX
835-938-5373 974-004-1348
EIGHTY ONE. BY 435-408-5695
SEVENTY SEVEN. FIVE NINETY
EIGHT SIX TWENTY THREE SIX
THIRTY TO SIX THIRTY SEVEN SIX
THIRTY EIGHT S SEVEN
SEVENTEEN SEVEN FORTY SEVEN
SEVEN NINE SEVEN EIGHTY TWO
SEVEN EIGHTY SIX SEVEN AS YOU ARE
TWENTY ONE IS YOUR THIRTY ONE
IT IS YOUR DUTY TO. THANK YOU
AND THAT CONSENT CALENDAR GETS
OUT ON A ROLL CALL. MADAM
SECRETARY COULD PLEASE. READ
THE BILLS THAT HAVE BEEN MOVED
TO THE SUSPENSE FILE. SB.
671-023-2420 934-404-0240. FOUR
FIFTY ONE FIFTY THREE FIFTY
EIGHT FIFTY NINE SIXTY THREE.
SIXTY SIX ONE THIRTY SIX ONE
THIRTY SEVEN ONE FORTY TO ONE
FORTY FIVE ONE SIXTY ONE. SEVENTY SIX ONE SEVEN
NINE ONE EIGHTY FOUR ONE EIGHTY
NINE ONE NINETY THREE ONE
NIN
202-206-2162 1-821-922-6230.
SEVEN TO THIRTY NINE TO FORTY
EIGHT TO FIFTY FIVE TO SIXTY TO
SIXTY FOUR. TO SIXTY FIVE TO
FIFTY NINE TO SEVENTY THREE TO
SEVENTY SEVEN. 842-892-9290.
429-832-8333 337-340-4340 NINE
THREE TWO. THREE SIXTY THREE
THREE SEVENTY FIVE THREE
SEVENTY SIX THREE EIGHTY TWO.
264-284-0140 240-946-2460 THREE
FOUR SIXTY FOUR FOUR SIXTY
FIVE. 788-440-7490 FIVE OR
THREE FIVE OH FOUR. BY
1-351-952-1530 BY THIRTY TWO BY
THIRTY FIVE FORTY BY FORTY ONE
BY THE KEYBOARD BY FIFTY FIVE
BY 595-745-8258 THREE FIVE
NINETY FIVE SIX HUNDRED SIX TWO
EIGHT. 1-661-161-3620
663-365-6516 666-366-8670 TWO
SIX EIGHTY THREE.
1-016-969-6976. NINETY EIGHT
SEVEN OH SIX SEVEN SIXTEEN
SEVEN THIRTY SEVEN SIXTY THREE
SEVEN SIXTY
FIVE. NINETY ONE. SO THANK YOU
ALL OF THOSE BILLS HAVE BEEN
MOVED TO THE SUSPENSE FILE IF
YOU FEEL THE NEED TO REGISTER
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION TO ONE OF
THE SUSPENSE BILLS AND THE
AUTHOR WAY PRESENTATION YOU MAY
STAND UP AT THE MICROPHONE TO
DO SO BEFORE WE STARTED PUBLIC
COMMENT I DO WANT TO NOTE THAT
AS BEFORE FIFTY BY MR UMBERG
WEST STEPFORD TODAY BUT HE'S
ASK FOR TO BE MOVED TO NEXT
WEEK AND SO WE WILL HEAR IT
NEXT WEEK. WITHOUT ANY SUPPORT
OPPOSITION TO ANY OF THE BILLS
AND SUSPENSE FILE. GOOD MORNING
MY NAME IS WHEN IT SELLS
DIRECTOR OF CALIFORNIANS FOR
LIFE AND I'M PROVIDING
TESTIMONY IN OPPOSITION TO SB
TWENTY FOUR. OKAY YOU'RE GOING
TO. TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION RIGHT
YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES TO DO
SOMETHING EXACTLY DESPITE
HAVING OVER TWO YEARS TO WORK
ON THIS BILL THE AUTHOR HAS
FAILED TO ADDRESS THE SERIOUS
FISCAL IMPLICATIONS INVOLVING
OVER THREE MILLION DOLLARS EACH
YEAR OF. UNFUNDED MANDATES.
BOTH UC AND CSU INDICATE THIS
BILL AND I QUOTE MAY REQUIRE
ADDITIONAL GENERAL FUNDS ARE
STUDENT FEES TO COVER START UP
COSTS. AND ESTIMATES ONGOING
GENERAL FUND OR STUDENT FEE
COST PRESSURES TO BE QUOTE AS
HIGH AS MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
SYSTEM WIDE EACH YEAR. THE
IMPORTANT QUESTION IS WHAT
HAPPENS AFTER JANUARY FIRST TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY THREE. AT FIVE
HUNDRED ABORTIONS ESTIMATED PER
MONTH AND PROJECTED AVERAGE
COST OF SIX HUNDRED DOLLARS
PROPORTION. THAT IS OVER THREE
POINT SIX MILLION DOLLARS EACH
YEAR OF UNFUNDED MANDATE WHO
WILL PAY FOR THIS. NEITHER SO
YOU'RE SURE YOU SEE ARE
EQUIPPED TO START BILLING
STUDENTS INSURANCE COMPANIES.
BOTH A BASS THE AUTHOR FOR
SPECIFIC AMENDMENTS TO REMOVE
REFERENCES AND POTENTIAL
REQUIREMENTS FOR C. S. H. SEES
TO BILL. BUT THE AUTHOR HAS NOT
ACCEPTED SAID AMENDMENTS. HOW
MUCH WILL THE UNIVERSITY'S
CHARGE THEIR STUDENTS FOR THESE
CHEMICAL ABORTION PILLS WELL
THEY CHARGE THE INFLATED
INDUSTRY PRICE OF SIX HUNDRED
DOLLARS OVER THE CHARGE THE
ACTUAL. COSTA PROVIDING THE
ABORTION PILLS WHICH COST ONLY
EIGHTY DOLLARS HOST CELL. THE
ASSEMBLY HIGHER EDUCATION
COMMITTEE HAS MADE THIS
IMPORTANT POINT QUOTE ON CAMPUS
HEALTH CENTERS COULD OFFER
MEDICATION ABORTION AT A LOWER
COST BECAUSE ON CAMPUS HEALTH
CENTERS WOULD NOT NEED TO
CHARGE THAT TO COVER FACILITY
OVERHEAD. THERE WILL BE
INCREASED LIABILITY COSTS THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS CONTINUES OF
A STUDENT WHO RECEIVES A
PORSCHE MY MEDICATION SHOULD
EXPERIENCE ADVERSE REACTIONS
AND SUFFER BODLEY OR EMOTIONAL
HARM OR WORSE DEATH WHO IS
LIABLE. DOES THIS BILL CREATE A
SITUATION OR BY MONIES THAT
COULD BE USED FOR OTHER VITAL
STUDENT SUPPORT. BE RE DIRECT
RE DIRECTED IN ORDER TO PAY FOR
PERSONAL INJURY LAW CASES.
ADDITIONALLY WHAT HAPPENS IF
THE OLDER SON WAS NOT PERFORMED
CORRECTLY YOU HAVE AND I
SECONDS. FOR ALL OF THESE
REASONS. WE ENCOURAGE YOU TO
VOTE NO ONE SB TWENTY FOUR
RETRACT THIS MONEY TO ACTUALLY
HELP STUDENTS COMPLETE THEIR
EDUCATIONAL GOALS WITHOUT
HAVING TO KILL THEIR CHILDREN
HIM. WE OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU. PLEASE STATE THE BILL AND
YOUR POSITION. SENATOR BILL SIX
NINE SIX. SENSUALLY DESIGNED TO
DO AWAY WITH AMERICAN
INDEPENDENT PARTY. TIME PHELPS
HOBART WITH THE- AMERICAN
INDEPENDENT PARTY STATE CENTRAL
COMMITTEE. AND WE ARE STRONGLY
OPPOSED AND WAS THAT THIS BILL
JUST DIED. THANK YOU. HI I'M
I'M WE ARE SPEAKING IN
OPPOSITION TO SP ONE EIGHTY
NINE HI MY NAME I'M SORRY IF
YOU IT DOESN'T BE HELPFUL FOR
ME IF YOU CAN NAME THE AUTHOR
OF THE PIECE OF A SHIRT SENATOR
MONEY OKAY SB ONE EIGHTY NINE
THANK YOU MY NAME IS LANE LONG
I'M THE CITY MANAGER OF THE
CITY OF MARINA ON BEHALF OF
MAYOR DELGADO INNER CITY
COUNCIL. I WE RESPECTFULLY URGE
YOU TO ALLOW FOR TO SEND SAID
IN JUNE TWENTY TWENTY IS
CURRENTLY PROVIDED BY STATE LAW
AND NOT APPROVED SB ONE EIGHTY
NINE WE'LL TO EXTEND FOR
ANOTHER TWO YEARS THE ISSUE IS
PRETTY SIMPLE EXTENSION OF FOUR
WILL DIRECTLY COST THE STATE
APPROXIMATELY HALF A MILLION
DOLLARS PER YEAR IN DIRECT COST
IT WILL COST THE STATE
SIGNIFICANTLY MORE IN INDIRECT
COSTS BY PREVENTING READ IT AND
SEE SIDE FROM HAVING ACCESS TO
FINANCIAL ANOTHER RESOURCES
THAT WE WOULD ALLOCATE TOWARDS.
AFFORDABLE HOUSING BLIGHTED
STRUCTURING MOVIL HOMELESSNESS
WATER AUGMENTATION AND OTHER
CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS.
FOR A COMMUNITIES. THESE.
CURRENTLY RIGHT NOW ARE
NONSENSICAL PRIORITIES ARE
ESTABLISHED BY THE FOR BOARD
AND ARE NOT APPROVED BY MARIN
AND SEASIDE. 75% OF THE
REMAINING DEVELOP OF FORMER
FORDER LAND RESIDES IN THE
BOUNDARIES ARENA AND SEASIDE
YET IT IS CONTROLLED BY THE
COUNTY THE ABIDING COMMUNITIES
A MODERATE DEL REY OAKS AND
CITY AND ALSO CARMEL IN PACIFIC
GROVE. THIS VOTING MAJORITY FOR
TWENTY SIX YEARS HAS PRIORITIZE
NONSENSICAL ROAD IN OTHER.
PROJECTS TO THE BENEFIT OF
THESE COMMUNITIES AT THE COST
OF CRITICAL BLIGHT REMOVAL
WATER AUGMENTATION HABITAT
MANAGEMENT AND AFFORDABLE
HOUSING ARE IN OUR COMMUNITIES.
IN THE LAST FIVE YEARS MARINO
HAS CONTRIBUTED MORE THAN FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS TO FOUR LAND
SALES. THROUGH LAND SALES AND
DEVELOPMENT FEES YET NONE OF
THAT HAS RETURNED BACK TO OUR
COMMUNITY AGAIN FOR THE
CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE BLIGHT
REMOVAL FOR WILL HOUSING. THAT.
WE NEED IN OUR COMMUNITY FIVE
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY EIGHT.
BLIGHTED MILITARY STRUCTURE
STILL RESIDE IN OUR COMMUNITY
AND NEED TO BE TORN DOWN. IF
TEN MORE SECONDS. THIS IS ALL
FINANCIAL AND IT FOR EXTENSION
WILL COST THE STATE MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS IT WILL COST THE CITY
OF MARINE IN SEASIDE TENS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS MORE IF IT
IS IF IT IS EXTENDED WE URGE
YOU NOT TO EXTEND IT LOUD. TO
EXPIRE THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MARIO GUERRERO ON
BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA FACULTY
ASSOCIATION JUST WANT TO
REGISTER SUPPORT FOR SB TWENTY
FOUR. CENTER LEYVA AND VERY
BRIEFLY WITH REGARDS TO SB SIX
SIXTY BY DOCTOR PAN WE ARE THE
SPONSORS OF THE BILL. JUST
WANTED TO NOTE THAT IN LAST
YEAR'S BUDGET THERE IS TWENTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS THAT WAS
APPROPRIATED. TO HIRE TENURE
TRACK FACULTY THIS YEAR THERE
WAS THIRTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
TO HIRE TENURE TRACK FACULTY
BOTH OF THESE PARTS OF FUNDING
CAN BE USED TO HIRE COUNSELORS
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU.
THIS IS PUSH ON WITH THE UC
STUDENT ASSOCIATION ARE WE
WANTED TO REGISTER SUPPORT FOR
SB TWENTY FOUR AND ALSO
MENTIONED THAT YOU KNOW WE ARE
PROUD TO BE SUPPORTING. THIS
BILL THIS BILL PROVIDES MET.
NECESSARY MEDICAL CARE FOR ALL
WOMEN AT OUR COLLEGE CAMPUSES
AND SO THAT'S A DECISION THAT
IS LEFT WITH THE BEST LEFT WITH
THE STUDENTS AND OUR STUDENTS
HAVE SPOKEN THE SUPPORT THIS
BILL. AND THE APPRECIATE THAT
THE MEMBERS ALSO SUPPORTED ALSO
WANTED TO REGISTER OUR SUPPORT
FOR IF TO WATER BILLS ONES. SB
SIX NINETY EIGHT BOB IS A BILL
BY THE BE HEAVILY SUPPORT AND
AS WELL AS OUR- OUR FELLOW.
FULL SAID YOU A W. WE ARE
SUPPORTIVE OF THE OF THIS BILL
AS WELL AS SB ONE THIRTY SIX
OUR WHICH AS A PART OF THE
LARGER COLLISION. I CALIFORNIA
UNITED FOR RESPONSIBLE BUDGET
WE WOULD LIKE TO RESPECTFULLY
ASK THAT THE COMMITTEE PASSES
THIS BILL WITHOUT ANY
AMENDMENTS. BECAUSE WE FEEL
VERY STRONGLY THAT THE BILL AS
WRITTEN IS. IT'S DOING WHAT
IT'S SUPPOSED TO DO THANK YOU
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING
CHAIRWOMAN COMMITTEE MEMBERS
SO. PUT A CASTEEL ON BEHALF OF
THE LOS ANGELES JAGANNATH CALL
POLICY ALLIANCE AND THE
CALIFORNIA CALL POLICY
ALLIANCE. WE'RE HERE IN
OPPOSITION TO SB FIFTY EIGHT
SCOTT WINNER THE FOR YOUR
BARBELL. A STUDY BY THE ALCOHOL
RESEARCH GROUP IN THE PUBLIC
HEALTH INSTITUTE. HAS ESTIMATED
THAT THEY'LL BE A COST OF SEVEN
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS TO ALL
NINE CITIES IN THE STATE OF
THIS BILL IS IMPLEMENTED AT A
CONSERVATIVE RATE OF 5% SO THE
5% OF ALL BARS AND RESTAURANTS
IN THE CITIES WHERE TO GO TO
FOR I AM THERE WOULD BE A COST
OF SEVEN HUNDRED MORE. MILLION
DOLLARS TO THE STATE. ON TOP OF
THE CURRENT FOURTEEN BILLION
DOLLARS AT THE STATE. HAS TO
ANCHOR BECAUSE ABOUT THE HARMS
SO BE REQUEST NO VOTE THANK YOU.
KIM. MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS DINNER
FEEL ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA RENTAL HOUSING
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF TWO
BILLS SB TWO FORTY EIGHT MR
GLAZER AND SB FIVE TWENTY ONE
MISTER PORTANTINO THANK YOU
THANK YOU. REBEKAH GONZALEZ
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB TWENTY
FOUR WHERE WANT TO SUPPORT
WOMEN'S AT CHOICE AND
REPRODUCTIVE FREEDOM THERE ARE
OTHER BILLS ON CALENDAR THAT WE
ARE IN SUPPORT OF BUT WE HAVE
SUBMITTED LETTERS AND WE'LL
LEAVE IT AT THAT THANK YOU. I
KNOW THAT WE'VE HAD TO SPEAKERS
IN SUPPORT OF SB TWENTY FOUR
AND SO IF ANYONE ELSE IS HERE
ON THAT BE HAPPIER JUST STATE
YOUR NAME AND YOUR POSITION.
ELIZABETH ASK OF ALL OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
SCHOOL BUSINESS OFFICIALS HERE
IN OPPOSITION TO SB THREE
TWENTY A BY SENATOR PORTANTINO.
WHILE THE EXACT COST TO LOCAL
G. EIGHT LOW LOCAL EDUCATIONAL
AGENCIES WILL VARY MANDATING A
LATER START TIME COULD CREATE
SIGNIFICANT LAW LOCAL COST
PRESSURES. SUCH AS AN INCREASE
IN DEMAND FOR BEFORE AND AFTER
SCHOOL PROGRAMS WITH AN
INCREASE IN STAFF FOR
SUPERVISION AN INCREASE IN THE
COST OF TRANSPORTATION SERVICES
DUE TO LESS FLEXIBILITY IN
SCHEDULING TRANSPORTATION
INCLUDING. LIMIT TRANSPORTATION.
THIS IS A STATE WIDE THE BILL
CREATES A STATEWIDE MANDATE
THAT CAN COST IN THE UPWARDS OF
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
WITH AN ADDITIONAL FUNDING
PROVIDED FOR IT. THANK YOU
THANK YOU. A GOOD MORNING CHAIR
AND MEMBERS SURELY DOWN BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL VERSUS
YUSHIN ALSO IN OPPOSITION SB
THREE TWENTY PORTANTINO. JUST
WOULD LIKE TO STATE THAT WHILE
THE SCIENCE IS NOT CLEAR AS FAR
AS BEING A SILVER BULLET TO
THIS ISSUE. ON THAT THE FISCAL
IMPACTS ON WORKING IN LOW
INCOME FAMILIES IS VERY REAL
AND WILL BE DEVASTATING TO
THOSE. THANK YOU WE'VE NOW HAD
TWO SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION TO
SB THREE TWENTY EIGHT SO ANYONE
ELSE HERE IN OPPOSITION NEEDS
TO JUST STATE THEIR NAME AND
POSITION WHAT THREE TWENTY
EIGHT. WHEN IT'S A LATE START
TIME BILL. YOU MAY PROCEED ON
ANY OTHER BUT I JUST WANNA MAKE
SURE NOBODY STAR ARMENIAN BRIAN
BRAK MIA UC SANTA BARBARA CLASS
OF NINETEEN EIGHTY IN
OPPOSITION TO TWENTY FOUR. AM I
ALSO M. IN SUPPORT OF THE PIER.
HERE MENTAL HEALTH PROGRAM AS
WELL AS I DON'T KNOW THE
NUMBERS AS WELL AS BIG YOU
HAVING FORMERLY HOMELESS PEOPLE
ON THE COMMISSION THAT THE
PERSON WHO WAS HOMELESS. EIGHTY
ONE NINETEEN EIGHTY ONE TO
EIGHTY TWO AND AS A PERSON WITH
A- SITE WITH MENTAL HEALTH
CHALLENGES AYE SO I HAVE
BENEFITTED FROM PEER SUPPORT. I
APPRECIATE YOUR POSITION THAT
BILL WAS HEARD EARLIER BUT
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS PAMELA GIVES
REPRESENTING THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION IN
SUPPORT OF A COUPLE OF BILLS
THAT I MENTIONED AND JUST
BRIEFLY SB SEVEN SIXTEEN
MITCHELL THIS IS THE BILL THAT
PROVIDES INCARCERATED YOUTH WHO%
HAVE HIGH SCHOOL DIPLOMAS. WITH
ACCESS TO OTHER POST SECONDARY
EDUCATION AND SEE TV PROGRAM SO
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THAT BILL
ALSO SB TWO NINETEEN WHICH IS
THE CALIFORNIA FOSSEY'S IN
RICHMOND GRANT PILOT PROGRAM
AND WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THAT
BILL. BOTH BILLS SEEM TO HAVE
REASONABLE COST AND WE
APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEES
ANALYSIS ON THOSE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TIME THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING STEVE BALK
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE ALL NEW
TO CONTRA COSTA TRANSIT
DISTRICT ARE ALSO HERE IT'S AN
OPPOSITION SB THREE TWENTY
EIGHT. THIS IS A BILL THAT
WOULD HAVE A HAVE A SNIFF IT
THIS COMPACT ON AC TRANSIT'S
OPERATING BUDGET. BY INCREASING
IT SAID NEED FOR TRANSPORTATION
COSTS BY OVER SIXTY PERCENT SO.
YOUR G. TO KEEP THAT ON SPENT
FILE. THANK YOU. DAVID NEVIN ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION SCHOOL
TRANSPORTATION OFFICIALS IN
OPPOSITION TO SB THREE TWENTY
ANTHONY PORTANTINO ALL ONE MY
COMMENTS FOR THE PRIOR
SPEAKERS. THANK YOU. MORNING
MADAM CHAIR RANCHERO THE
RIVERSIDE SHERIFF'S ASSOCIATION
I WASN'T GOING TO SPEAK TODAY
ON SENATE BILL ONE THIRTY SIX
BY CENTER WIENER BUT SOMEBODY
BROUGHT UP IN SUPPORT. ON
BEHALF OF THE THOUSANDS MEMBERS
OF THE RIVERSIDE SHERIFF'S
ASSOCIATION WE OPPOSE SB ONE
THIRTY SIX THAT SEEKS TO REDUCE
THE SENTENCES FOR CONVICTED
REPEAT VIOLENT CRIMINALS.
UNLIKE OTHER RECENT MEASURES
THE REMOVED MANDATORY SENSE
ENHANCEMENTS AND REPLACE THEM
WITH THE JUDICIAL DISCRETION.
ONE THIRTY SIX ACCOMPLISHES THE
OPPOSITE. THIS BILL INSTEAD
STRIPS THE JUDICIARY OF ITS
AUTHORITY TO BALANCE CERTAIN
CERTAIN MANAGEMENT. IN THE
INTEREST OF JUSTICE. SB ONE
THIRTY SIX WILL REDUCE
SENTENCES FOR SOME OF THE MOST
DANGEROUS ABOUT VIRTUAL
CRIMINALS AND ELIMINATE THE
CURRENT LAW THE PROVIDES FOR
JUDICIAL DISCRETION SENSING WE
BELIEVE THAT THE CRIMINALS
TARGETED IN THIS BILL. FOR
SINCE REDUCTION ARE THE VERY
LAST CONVICTS BUT SHOULD HAVE
THEIR SENTENCES REDUCED TO THE
PUBLIC SAFETY RISKS INHERENT IN
ALLOWING HARDEN VIOLENT CREEK
CRIMINALS TO GET OUT OF PRISON
EARLY RECESSION ASSOCIATION
MOST STRONGLY OPPOSE SB ONE
THIRTY SIX. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ONE LAST PUBLIC COMMENT. JUST
ABOUT THE WESTERN CENTER ON LAW
AND POVERTY. GIVING SUPPORT FOR
TWO BILLS THAT WERE OPPOSED SB
TWENTY FOUR AND ALSO FOR SB ONE
THIRTY SIX. THANK YOU WITH THAT
THAT CONCLUDES THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE AS APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEES